This is Jocko podcast number
85 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
I was given a very old man who could not
or would not keep up with this country
man because he repeatedly fell
and then simply lay there.
I regularly had to lift him
up and drag him forward. Thus,
I only reached the execution site
when my comrades had already shot.
They're Jews at the site of his
country, men who had been shot.
My Jiu threw himself on the
ground and remained lying there.
I then cocked my car being and shot
him through the back of the head
because I was already very upset from the
cruel treatment of the Jews during the
clearing of the town and was
completely in turmoil. I shot too high.
The entire back of the skull of my
Jew was torn off and the brain exposed
parts of the skull flew into
Sergeant Steinmetz, his face.
This was grounds for me.
After returning to the truck to go to the
first sergeant and ask for my release,
I had become so sick that
I simply couldn't anymore.
I was then relieved
by the first surgeon.
Okay.
Systematic murder.
That's what we're talking about.
This is the Nazis final solution,
which was not always carried out
in the relatively detached method.
Often fond of when we
think of the Holocaust
cause when we think of the Holocaust,
a lot of times we think of this
big mechanism we think of trains,
we think of gas chambers,
we think of process.
We think of a massive bureaucratic
machine that is doing the killing
in in.
Maybe that in some way is easier for us
to understand and that's where we focus
on that piece.
It's easier for us to accept that,
but it wasn't all like that.
Many lives were taken many
murders committed by hand,
close range,
point blank,
so what kind of
monsters
committed.
Those are trustees,
those personal atrocities up close
and personal murders that covered the
murderers in the blood of their victims.
What?
What kind of men were those
and how did they end up there
and what can we do
to prevent it from occurring again
now to answer or at least try
and come to some understanding.
We're going to explore a book
that is called ordinary men,
reserve police battalion 101 and the
final solution in Poland written by
Christopher are browning.
And that first excerpt that I read is
from that book and it's from a soldier in
the police battalion named August Zorn.
And that's actually a, a pseudonym.
The names were changed for
some of the Nazis in the book,
but the book is
incredibly detailed in what happened
and where these men were from and
what unfolded.
And obviously this is going
to be a graphic episode
and you,
you know,
I actually wish I didn't
have to talk about this.
I do. I really do. I wish I
could talk about nicer things.
I wish I could talk about pleasant
things and we could just forget about all
this horror.
But Aye,
there's the rub because
even though it would be easier and more
pleasant to talk about something nice,
the problem is that if we
forget about these things,
then we forget about these things
and if we forget,
we don't learn.
And if we don't learn about what humans
can do and why they do what they do,
then we can repeat our mistakes in.
That is awful.
Yeah,
so yeah,
we go because we have to go.
Can we go back to the book?
Okay.
Just as the sky was beginning to lighten
the convoy halted outside yourself,
it was a typical Polish village of modest
white houses with thatched straw roofs
among its inhabitants war 1800 Jews.
The village was totally quiet.
The men of Reserve Police Battalion,
one o one climbed down from their trucks
and assembled in the half circle around
their commander,
Major Ville helm trap,
a 53 year old career policemen,
affectionately known by
his men as papa trap.
The time had come for trap to address the
men and inform them of the assignment.
The battalion had received
Pale and nervous with choking
voice and tears in his eyes
trap visibly fought to control himself.
As he spoke
the battalion,
he said plaintiff Lee had to perform
a frightfully unpleasant task.
This assignment was not to his liking.
Indeed, it was highly regrettable,
but the orders came from
the highest authorities.
If it would make the task any easier
than men should remember that in Germany
the bombs were falling
on women and children.
Then he turned to the matter at hand.
The Jews had instigated the American
boy cop that it damaged Germany.
One policeman remembered trap saying
there were Jews in the village of
Yosef Ove who were involved with the
partisans.
He explained according to two others,
the battalion had now been
ordered to round up these Jews,
the male Jews of working age where to
be separated and taken to a work camp.
The remaining Jews,
the women,
children and elderly were to be
shot on the spot by the battalion.
Having explained awaited his men trapped
made them an extraordinary offer.
If any of the older men among them did
not feel up to the task that lay before
them,
he could step out.
Trap paused,
and after some moments,
one man from third company,
Aldo,
Julius Schimke,
stepped forward.
Captain Hoffman who had arrived in
Yosef directly from Zaccaro with third
platoon of third company and had not been
part of the officers' meetings the day
before was furious that one of his
men had been the first to break rakes.
Hoffman begin to Berate Schimke,
but trap caught him off after he had
taken Schimke under his protection.
Some 10 or 12 other men
stepped forward as well.
They turned in their rifles and we're
told to await a further assignment from
the major,
so we'll go into this,
but you've got to
a battalion three companies,
there's probably 500 men and we have,
they get this s savage order that
they're going to go and shoot
the women,
children and elderly on the spot in this
village with pretty white houses and
the commander, this guy trap who
obviously isn't comfortable with it,
he's got tears in his eyes when
he's given this order. He says, Hey,
if anybody doesn't want to participate,
you can step forward now and like 10
or 12 people out of 500 step forward.
The rest of them hold the line.
In this case,
going back to the book,
trapped then summoned the company
commanders and gave them the respect of
assignments.
The orders were relayed
by the platoon commanders,
two platoons, a third company
where to surround the village.
The men were explicitly ordered
to shoot anyone trying to escape.
The remaining men were to round up the
Jews and take them to the marketplace.
Those too sick or frail to walk to the
marketplace as well as infants and anyone
offering resistance. We're attempting
to hide where to be shot on the spot.
Thereafter,
a few men of the first company were
escorted where do escort the work Jews who
had been selected at the marketplace
while the rest of first company was to
proceed to the forest
to form firing squads.
The Jews were to be loaded onto battalion
trucks by second company and Third
Platoon of third company and shuttled
from the marketplace to the forest,
and that's for executions.
Yeah.
After making the assignments trap.
Spent most of the day in town either
in a schoolroom converted into his
headquarters at the homes of the Polish
mayor and at the local priest at the
marketplace or on the road to the forest,
but he did not go to the forest
itself or witness the executions.
His absence.
There was conspicuous as one
policeman bitterly commented.
Major trap was never there.
Instead of you remained in Yosef wove
because he could allegedly could not bear
the sight
we met were upset about that and
said we couldn't bear it either.
Indeed,
traps distress was a secret
to no one at the marketplace.
One policeman remembered hearing
traps wrote, say, Oh God,
why did I have to be given these
orders as he put his hand on his heart,
another policeman witness
Tim at the schoolhouse today.
I can see exactly before my
eyes made your trap in the room,
pacing back and forth with
his hands behind his back.
He made a downcast impression and spoke
to me. He said something like, man,
such jobs don't suit me,
but orders are orders.
Another man remembered vividly how trap
finally alone nor room sat on a stool
and wept bitterly.
The tiers really flowed.
Yeah.
Can you hear that?
That idea that orders
are orders doesn't stand,
doesn't work.
Back to the book.
As the roundup neared completion,
the men are first company were withdrawn
from the search and give them a quick
lesson in the gruesome
task that awaited them.
They were instructed by the battalion
doctor and the company's first Sargent,
and this is a quote from one of the men.
I believe that at this point all the
officers of the battalion were present,
especially our battalion physician,
Dr Schoenfelder.
He now had to explain to us precisely how
we had to shoot in order to induce the
immediate death of the victim.
I remember exactly that.
For this demonstration, he'd you or
outlined the contours of a human body,
at least from the shoulders upward and
then indicated precisely the point on
which the fixed bayonet was to
be placed as an aiming guide.
So we have the battalion doctor who's
instructing some of the men and you're
going to see that it wasn't all
of them to take the bayonet,
which is on their rifle,
put it on the back of the
neck as an aiming guide to
know where exactly where to
shoot.
Okay.
Back to the book.
First Sergeant Camer had taken the
initial contingent of shooters in first
company to a forest several
kilometers from Yosef.
The truck's halted on a dirt road that
ran along the edge at a point where a
pathway led into the woods. The men
climbed down from their trucks and waited.
When the first truck load of 35 to 40
Jews arrived and equal number of policemen
came forward and face to face
were paired off with their victims
led by or the policemen and Jews
marched down the forest path.
They turned off into the woods at
a point indicated by captain Wolof,
who busied himself throughout the day,
selecting the execution sites.
Camera then ordered the
Jews to lie down in a row.
The policeman stepped up behind them,
place their bayonets on the backbone
above the shoulder blade as instructed
earlier and on cameras
command fired in unison.
In the meantime,
more policemen of first company had
arrived at the edge of the forest to fill
out a second firing squad.
As the first firing squad marched out
of the woods to the unloading point,
the second group took their victims
along the same path into the woods.
Well,
half chose a site a few yards farther on,
so the next batch of victims would
not see the corpses from the earlier
execution.
These Jews were again forced to lie
face down in a row and the shooting
procedure was repeated.
Thereafter,
the pendulum traffic of the two firing
squads in and out of the woods continued
throughout the day
except for a midday break.
The shooting proceeded without
interruption until nightfall.
At some point in the afternoon,
someone organized a supply
of alcohol for the shooters.
By the end of the day of
nearly continuous shooting,
the medic completely lost track of how
many Jews they had each killed in the
words of one policeman. It was,
in any case, a great number.
So clearly this is not what we think
of when we think of the Holocaust.
Go Ben being paired off with their victims
to take out in the woods and shot in
the back of the head.
Yeah,
and going through this
procedure the entire day.
Back to the book.
In contrast to first company,
the men of second company received no
instruction on how to carry out the
shooting initially bay,
and that's we're not fixed as an
aiming guide and as herder noted,
there was a considerable number of
missed shots that led to the unnecessary
wounding of the victims.
One of the policemen and
hurts unit likewise noted
the difficulty the men had an
aiming properly. At
first, we shot free hand.
When one aim too high, the entire
skull exploded. As a consequence,
brains and bones flew everywhere.
Thus we were instructed to place
the bay in that point on the neck.
According to hergert.
However,
using fixed bayonets as an
aiming guide was no solution.
Through the point blank shot though the
point blank shot that was thus required,
the bullet struck the head of the victim.
It's such a trajectory that
often the entire skull,
or at least the entire rear skullcap
was torn off and blood bone splinters in
brain sprayed everywhere and
[inaudible] to the shooters.
Her group was so in phatic that no one
had first platoon was given the option of
withdrawing beforehand,
but once the executions began and men
approached either him or sheer because
they could not shoot women and children,
they were given other duties.
This was confirmed by one of his men
during the execution word spread that
anyone could not take it
any longer could report.
He w he then went on to note,
I myself took part in some 10 shootings
in which I had to shoot men and women.
I simply could not
shoot at people anymore,
which became apparent to my sergeant
hergert because at the end I repeatedly
shot past. For this
reason, he relieved me.
Other comrades were all so relieved sooner
or later because they simply could no
longer continue.
So
obviously there's mixed emotions about
this whole thing from the top of the
chain of command right down
to the frontline shooters
that are only able to do
this so many times.
Some of them opt out of it initially,
but let's remember that it's still
taking place and no one's stopping it.
No ones. Some I'm saying some people
are excusing themselves from it,
but there's no one saying, Hey, what
the hell are we doing right now?
Back to the book,
some of the men who hurried at their
tasks shot far more Jews than others who
delayed as much as they could.
After two rounds,
one policeman simply slipped off and
stayed among the trucks at the edge of the
forest.
Another managed to avoid taking turn with
the shooters all together and here's a
quote from him.
It was in no way the case that those who
did not want to or could not carry out
the shooting of human beings with their
own hands could not keep themselves out
of the task. No strict control
was being carried out here.
I therefore remained by the arriving
trucks and kept myself busy.
At the arrival point. In any case, I
gave my activity such an appearance.
It could not be avoided.
That one or another of my comrades
noticed that I was not going to the
executions to fire away at the victims.
They showered me with remarks such as
shit head and weakling to express their
disgust,
but I suffered no
consequences for my actions.
I must mention here that I was not
the only one who kept himself out of
participating in the executions.
So guys,
like I said,
had figured out that they can not
participate if they don't want to
and they're getting called cowards
weaklings by the guys that are actually
cowards and weak links that are
going out and executing people.
Okay.
Back to the book.
As with first company,
alcohol was made available to the
policemen under Drucker and Steinmetz who
stayed in the forest
and continued shooting
as darkness approached at the end of a
long summer day and the murders task was
still not finished. The shooting became
even less organized and more hectic.
The forest was so full of dead bodies
that it was difficult to find places to
make the Jews lie down.
Okay.
So they complete this massacre and they
head back to their barracks and here we
go back to the book.
When the men arrived back at the barracks,
they were depressed,
angered in bittered and shaken the
eight little but drink heavily generous
quantities of alcohol were provided.
And many of the policeman got quite drunk.
Major trap made the rounds trying to
console and reassure them. And again,
placing the responsibility
on higher authorities,
placing responsibility on
higher authorities. You're
not allowed to do that.
Yeah,
but neither the drink nor
traps constellation could
wash away the sense of shame
and horror that pervaded the barracks.
So
that was the first police
action that they did this with.
This took place in Poland.
It was the first time that the group
had deployed to Poland and to give you,
you know, when you, we
hear what they did. Yeah.
You hear some people that that had a hard
time with it, but still, like I said,
that was a small percentage that was like
10% maybe 15% of people that said, no,
I'm not going to do her to that.
That he had or,
or made themselves busy with other things.
Most of the guys just went ahead
and did what they were told to do
and you think to yourself,
okay, well who were these guys?
Were they hardened combat veterans from
the front line where they were they
young sort of brainwashed
Nazi youth that were that.
That's what they believed
in and they just, they,
their minds just saw that as the reality
that they had to go through with,
and this is the strange thing about
this book is that that's not what it is.
That's not who these guys were.
And now I'll go to the book to
talk about who they actually were.
For the most part,
reserve reserve police battalion,
one o one was now composed of men without
any experience of German occupation
methods and eastern
Europe or for that matter,
with the exception of the very oldest
tool in world war one, veterans,
any kind of military service. Most of
these guys aren't even from the military.
The battalion consisted of 11 officers,
five administrative officials in charge
of financial matters relating to play in
political, uh, provisioning, lodging,
etc. And 486 noncommissioned
officers and men.
The battalion was divided
into three companies,
each of approximately 140
men when it full strength.
Two companies were commanded by police
captains and the third by certain senior
reserve lieutenant in that battalion.
Each company was divided into three
platoons to them commanded by reserve
lieutenants and the third by
a platoon senior sergeants.
So this is kind of a
normal military makeup.
The battalion was commanded by
53 year old, major Wilhelm trap,
World War One veteran and recipient
of the iron cross first class.
Now we know World War One obviously
was a brutal war and he's a survivor of
that,
awarded the Iron Cross first class
and fought for Germany and lost.
What do you do after the war?
Back to the book. After the war,
he became a career policemen
and rose through the ranks.
He had recently been promoted from
captain of second company and this was his
first battalion command.
Though trap had joined the Nazi party
in December of 1932 and thus technically
qualified as an old party
fighter or alter comfort.
He had never been taken into the ss or
even given an equivalent ss rank in spite
of the fact that Himmler and Heidrick
consciously tried to merge and intertwined
to state and
party components of their ss police.
Empire trap was clearly
not considered ss material.
So the, and, and you're going
to see this, these guys, I mean,
there's a war going on.
So why are these guys in a police
battalion as opposed to being on the front
lines fighting the war?
The reason is because they're not quite
the right material to go out and fight.
And by the way, this is, you know,
we're going to get to a point as soon in
the war where there's some 14 year old
to Hitler youth going out to fight, but
these guys aren't, aren't being selected.
Back to the book. He was soon to come
into conflict with his two captains,
both young ss men who even in their
testimony more than 20 years later made no
attempt to conceal their contempt for
their commander as weak unmilitary and
unduly interfering in the
duties of his officers.
So he's got a couple police captains
that were a little bit more hardcore.
Let me tell you about them.
Wolf Gang Hoffman.
He was born 19 1416 years old.
He was in Hitler youth in
1932 at 18 he was in the SS,
graduated from Gymnasium,
which is a college preparatory high
school in 1934 during the police force in
1936 I entered the Nazi party in 1937
same year completed police training was
commissioned as a lieutenant and now he's
in the reserves in 1942 reserve police
battalion one on one. So He'd, he'd come
up through the ranks, you know, as a Nazi,
but still, even him, I
mean, his formative years,
he's born in 1914 so, you know,
it's not like it's all he knew.
You know,
he went from 1914 until what,
1933 1930 so he was 16 years old.
He had been formed,
you know, lived as a normal German
before the Nazi party was around.
We're not talking a brainwashed,
complete Nazi youth.
Same thing with the other guy.
Born in 1913 this is Julius Wolff off.
Also graduated from Gymnasium,
joined the Nazi party
in 1933 1936 became ss.
So these guys are more, you know,
they're more engaged in the whole Nazi
party and obviously toeing
the line along that now.
So that's the two police captains
that are in charge of a couple of the
companies inside the battalion.
Now let's talk a little bit about the men.
The men aged generally
from 33 to 48 years old.
Uh,
five were party members.
None of them belong to the
SS of the back of the book.
Of the 32 noncommissioned officers
on whom we have information.
22 were party members and
seven were in the SS. They
ranged in age from 27 to 40 years old.
Their average age was 33 and a half.
They were not reservists,
but rather prewar recruits to
the police of the rank and file.
So now we're just
talking about the troops.
The 400 plus troops of the rank and file.
The vast majority of war
from the Hamburg area,
63% were working class background,
but fewer skilled laborers.
The majority of them held typical
Hamburg working class jobs,
dock workers and truck
drivers were most numerous,
but there are also many warehouse and
construction workers, machine operators,
seaman and waiters.
About 35% were lower middle class,
virtually all of them
white collar workers,
three quarters of them
were in sales of some sort.
The other one quarter form various office
jobs in both government and private
sector.
The number of under the number of
independent artisans and small businesses,
businessmen were very small.
Only a handful,
2% where middleclass profession
professionals and very
modest ones at that such
as drug tests and teachers.
The average age of the men was 39
over half were between 37 and 42 a
group considered too old for the army,
but most heavily conscripted for reserve
police duty after September, 1939.
So these guys, so the,
the men are, are there,
they're 30 40 years old,
35 40 years old.
These guys is if fully developed,
right? They're not, they're not. Yeah.
They're not impressionable guys that
are just raised inside the nautical too.
Cause I mean, let's face it,
if you're raised in any, uh,
cultish religion scenario,
there's a really good chance that if
that's what you're going to believe in and
you don't understand any other
way of thinking. So you can
know if you can be a good excuse,
but it's understandable how
you end up that way. Yeah.
Back to the book,
the men of Reserve Police Battalion were
from the lower orders of German society.
They'd experienced neither social nord,
geographic mobility by
virtue of their age.
And here's what we're just talking
about. By virtue of their age, of course,
all went through their formative
period in the pre Nazi era era.
These were men who had known political
standards and moral norms other than
those of the Nazis,
most came from Hamburg by reputation,
one of the least not to
find cities in Germany.
And the majority came from a social
class that had been Anti Nazi in its
political culture.
These men would not seem to have been
a very promising group from which to
recruit mass murderers on the half on
behalf of Nazi vision of a racial utopia
free of Jews.
And I think
that title list book is
ordinary men and that's why,
because that's what we're talking about
here. Ordinary men. I mean that's, that's,
that's about it.
Uh,
clear cross section of society
then you could come up with,
I mean you'd come up with the same cross
section of society in America once you
guys are working as construction
workers, waders, truck drivers,
dockworkers I mean that's what,
that's what people do. Oh,
what age are they? They're
35 40 years old. Okay.
Is that the group that you think is going
to be all you're gonna be able to take
out and get him to murder thousands
and thousands of people face to face.
Okay.
Now there's a section here
is the reflections on the
massacre itself and it's
talking about this first,
like I said,
this first thing that
took place in Yossef Wolf,
it was that their first big
action as a group. So here we go.
Back to the book at your associate at USF.
Amir doesn't,
men out of nearly 500 responded
instinctively to major traps,
offered a step forward and excuse
themselves from the impending mass murder.
Why was the number of men from the
beginning declared themselves who from the
beginning declare themselves unwilling
to shoot so small? Any kind of offers,
an explanation here.
It's like the suddenness of it.
And if people are kind of surprised
and I, I can make sense of that, right?
Like if I gave you time to
think, if I was like, hey echo,
we got to go do this thing right now,
you'd probably be like, okay, cool,
let's go do it. But if I said, hey, echo,
then we're going to go do something
tomorrow, tomorrow, you know,
I'll pick you up at 10 30,
let me know,
well now you have time to contemplate.
So he surprised him with it. Uh,
there's also,
obviously there was peer pressure,
right to conform and you know that
that's going to play a role in,
and we'll talk about that more later.
Going back to book, back to the book.
Nonetheless,
the act of stepping out that morning in
Yossef off meant leaving one's comrades
and admitting that one was too weak
or cowardly. Who would've dared?
One policeman declared emphatically to
lose face before the assembled troops.
If the questions posed to me why I shot
with the others in the first place,
said another who subsequently asked
to be excused after several rounds of
killing, I must answer that no
one wants to be thought a coward.
It was one thing to
refuse at the beginning.
He added and quite another to try
and shoot but not be able to continue
another policeman more aware of what
truly required courage said quite simply,
I was cowardly. So that person
gets it. Yeah. You know,
these people are that the shooters are
saying, hey, I don't want to be a coward,
so I wanted to go shoot when
actually to stand up and say no.
That's what would have taken real
moral core courage at these points and
obviously these guys knew what
they were doing was wrong.
They knew it. That's why they're,
some of them weren't able to continue.
Now,
speaking of cowardly,
here's a little section that I thought
you should be pointed out and we were
talking about this before the podcast,
how people rationalize things. Yeah.
Well listen to this rationalization.
Perhaps the most astounding
rationalization of all
was that of a 35 year old
metal worker from Bremerhaven quote,
I made the effort and it was possible
for me to shoot only children.
It's so happened that the mothers
led the children by the hand.
My neighbor then shot the mother and
I shot the child that belonged to her
because I reasoned with myself
that after all, without its mother,
the child could not live any longer.
It was supposed to be so to speak.
Soothing to my conscious
to release the children,
unable to live without their mothers.
And actually he goes in here and talks
about the German word for release also
means to like redeem or save.
So this guy's really twisted
things up in his head.
The dangers of rationalization
right there. Good God.
Back to the book with few exceptions,
the whole question of antisemitism is
marked by silence. So this is interesting.
This is very interesting. He the, as they,
and I should have
pointed this out earlier,
but this book is based on all these
different interviews and witness accounts,
mostly of the policemen
themselves. Now, and again,
I should have pointed
this out in the beginning.
Of course people are making
witness statements and
there's all kinds of problems
with those, right? They don't
remember things correctly.
They're trying to protect themselves,
they're trying to protect her friends,
they're trying to indict certain people
and make them look like the bad guy.
They might be trying to make themselves
look good. So there's all these
kind of angles that you have to listen
to the, you have to understand this with.
Yeah.
But this is interesting.
As they interview these guys back
to the book with few exceptions,
the whole question of
antisemitism is marked by silence.
What is clear is that the men's concerned
for their standing in the eyes of
their comrades was not matched by any
sense of human ties with their victims.
The Jews stood outside their circle of
human obligation and responsibility.
Such a polarization between us and them,
between one's comrades and the
enemy is of course standard in war.
And it is indeed.
But I guess what surprised me is these
guys weren't going in there with thinking
themselves,
okay,
these are the Jews that are doing us
wrong and we're going to get our chance.
They were just kind of
saying, well, they're not us,
so we'll do what we have to do.
Yeah,
back to the book,
even 20 or 25 years later,
those who did quit shooting along
the way overwhelmingly cited sheer,
physical revulsion against what
they were doing as the prime motive,
but the not express any
ethical or political principles
behind this revulsion.
So That's interesting.
These guys were stopping because it made
them feel sick and they weren't saying,
look, I need, so I am actually,
what I've been saying is like, Hey,
these guys knew it was wrong. Oh,
well they didn't think of it as wrong,
or at least this is explaining
that they weren't thinking, oh,
this is so wrong that their thinking was,
I'm going to be sick.
Now any rational person can figure out
that if something makes you sick to do,
then you've got some deep seeded
knowledge that what you're doing is wrong.
Yeah. Yeah. It seems like that that
was like the, the moral part of it,
right or wrong and stuff. That wasn't
the primary, the primary. It was just,
I can't take the blood and guts, man.
I can't take the blood and guts. Yeah,
you're exactly right. Now, like I said,
there's a connection and I don't
think he makes it in the book,
but in my mind there's a connection.
If you're doing something that
makes you feel sick. Yeah.
It's not just the making you feel sick.
That's should be bothering you.
What's should be bothering you is the
fact that you're doing something that
makes you feel sick. There's a
reason why it makes you feel sick.
There's a reason why human beings feel
sick when they're laying down children
shooting in the back of the head. There's
a reason for that. That's an, that's a,
that's a, it's like a, like a
survival instinct, right? For your,
for your species to carry on.
Yeah.
You have to make the other members
of your species survive. Yeah.
Especially if, if, just like,
are you saying they were,
there wasn't like some enemy kind
of feeling towards, you'd be like,
girl felt like, oh, we're defending
ourselves against this enemy. You know?
It wasn't that.
It was just that it was essentially
the minimum requirements and go against
somebody. They're not us and he's going
to go into this a little bit, but yeah,
you're right. It's not, it's not like
there's, yeah. He says, Hey, there's,
there's women and children being
bombed back in Germany right now,
but there's no direct correlation.
They're not saying, hey, look,
these Jews are fighting us. They're
gonna, they're gonna take over.
They've got ground in, you
know, on our borders. No,
not saying that they're actually in
total control of the Jews at this point,
or they're not total control,
but they're getting really close.
Getting really close.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
the resentment and bitterness in the
battalion over what they had been asked to
do, and Yosef was shared
by virtually everyone,
even those who had shot the entire day,
the exclamation of one policeman to first
sergeant camera of the first company
that I'd go crazy if I had to do that
again, express the sentiments of many.
But few went beyond complaining
to extricate themselves
from such a possibility.
So I said, hey, I bet why never
have to do that again. Yeah.
But very few of them said actually made
a stand the most dramatic back to the
book. The most dramatic response again
was that of Lieutenant Buckman who asked
trapped to have him transferred back
to Hamburg and declared that short of a
direct personal order from trap,
he would not take part in Jewish actions.
In the end,
he wrote to Hamburg explicitly requesting
a recall because he was not suited to
certain tasks, alien to the police that
were being carried out by his unit.
And Poland Buckman had waited,
had to wait until November,
but his efforts to be transferred
were ultimately successful.
So there's a guy that, that's one guy
that they're citing that actually said,
dude,
I'm not going to do this
now. It was bad enough and did have
a bad enough effect on the men.
And they complained about it
enough that there was some changes.
So here we go back to the book and
subsequent actions to vital changes were
introduced,
hence forth with some notable exceptions,
adhere to first most of the future
operations of the Reserve Po Police
Battalion,
one o one involved ghetto clearing and
deportation not outright massacre on the
spot.
The policemen were thus relieved of the
immediate horror of the killing process,
which for deportees from the northern
Logan district was carried out in the
extermination camp at Treblinka.
So now we're not going to,
you don't have to go shoot him.
You just got to gather them up and get,
uh,
get them shipped off to
the extermination camp.
Second while deportation was a
horrifying procedure characterized by the
terrible coercive violence needed to
drive people onto the death trains,
as well as the systematic killing of
those who could not be marched to the
trains.
These actions were generally undertaken
jointly by units of Reserve Police
Battalion,
one on one and the tro Tro,
Nikki's ss trained auxiliaries from the
Soviet territory's recruited from the
Russian POW camps and usually assigned
to the very worst parts of that ghetto
clearing and deportation.
So imagine this group,
you get a group of thugs that are
from Russian pow camps and you say,
Oh yeah, we'll let you out of this
pow camp and you can come work for us.
Mm,
yeah. And they're trained by the SS. No,
not exactly a friendly crew of guys.
In fact, that's like, I can't imagine
a worse group of people to come in and
come after you. Yeah. Back to the book.
The bulk of the killing was to be
removed to the extermination camp and the
worst of the, on the spot dirty work
was to be assigned to the [inaudible].
This change would prove sufficient to
allow the men of Reserve Police Battalion
One on one to become accustomed to their
participation in the final solution.
When the time came to kill again,
the policeman did not go crazy.
Instead they became increasingly
efficient and catalyst executioners.
So a couple of changes.
It was obviously it was a little too
much for them to actually do all the
killing themselves.
Now they got some people to help them
out and or they are just going to gather
them up and ship them away and they hold.
Now the only plan,
a little piece in the, in the,
in the, in the machine, right.
Just a little piece of machine.
So it's a lot easier to detach
from what's actually happening.
Back to the book that Jews have low
Mazi where to be the target of reserve
battalion. One on ones.
First joint killing action
with a unit from the Truckee
second company was to provide the
bulk of the manpower for the roundup.
The primary function of the tourniquets
was unit was to provide the shooters,
thus alleviating the chief psychological
burden the German policemen had
experienced at Yoseph.
And here the,
the orders come out,
they're going in and
now there's another term
that comes up. It's, it's,
it has to do with the tourniquets,
but it's he Weise and it's short.
I forget what the German words are,
but he always is short
for two big German words.
One of them that means a willing
and one of them that means helper.
So they called these,
these sort of people that had come
to the German side and we're not,
they called them [inaudible] and it's
like I said, it stands for willing helper.
It's like,
it's like using,
you ever heard the term Spec war for
that stance where special warfare,
this is the same thing with German to
German words that mean willing helper.
So here we go. Back to the book,
the NCO is, we're told that the,
he always from trawniki
would do the shooting,
so the policeman would for the
most part be spared. Nonetheless,
the roundup was to be conducted
as had been done before,
which is to say that infants and the old
sick and frail who could not be easily
taken to the assembly point
where to be shot on the spot.
So not out of all the killing
according to one squad leader,
however most children will once again
brought to the assembly point as in Yosef,
the men encountered not only German
Jews but specifically Hamburg Jews.
During the clearing action,
the Jews quickly filled the school yard
and overflowed into the adjoining sports
field with some shooting.
The roundup was finished
in two short hours.
So that's it.
That's a real sort of a one sentence
and if you can just try and imagine what
the hell is going on there. These
soldiers, these Russian soldiers,
these German soldiers are coming
in and rounding people up.
They're using violence,
shooting people to get all
the Jews into the school yard.
This is a nightmare scenario that they,
that you know,
he puts into a sentence here,
back to the book,
the 1700 Jews of Lumosity,
we're then forced to sit and wait.
A group of 60 to 70 young
men were selected out,
given shovels and spades loaded
onto trucks and driven to the woods.
Several of the young Jews jumped from
the moving trucks and made good their
escape.
Another attack to German corporal,
the battalion boxing championing champion
who promptly knocked his desperate
assailant senseless
in the woods.
The Jews were set to digging a mass grave
back in low Mazi.
The weight of the doom Jews and their
police guard stretched into hours.
Suddenly a contingent of 50 he weaves
from [inaudible] marched into town,
led by German ss officer.
I can still remember it exactly.
One policeman testified that immediately
after the arrival of these Trani keys
took a break. After their arrival,
the tourniquets took a break.
I saw that in addition to food,
they also took out bottles of vodka
out of their packs and drank from them,
the SS officer and Nad.
This is a guy that arrived on the scene.
Now grenade began
drinking heavily as well.
The other NCO smelled of alcohol,
but unlike the two commanders
were not visibly drunk.
So these guys are are drinking vodka and
they know what they're about to have to
go do. Now we're talking about
this guy, lieutenant nade.
Lieutenant Nade was a Nazi by
conviction and an anti Semite.
He was also unpredictable,
affable,
and approachable at times of
brutal and vicious at others.
And here's an eyewitness account from
one of those soldiers back to the book.
Even before the shooting began.
First Lieutenant Nade had personally
picked out some 20 to 25 elderly Jews.
They were exclusively
men with full beards.
Nade made the old men crawl on the
ground in the area before the grave,
before he gave them the order to crawl.
They had to undress while the
totally naked jewel Jews crawled,
first lieutenant made scream to those
around where my noncommissioned officers,
don't you have any clubs yet?
The noncommissioned officers
went to the edge of the forest,
fetched themselves clubs,
and vigorously beat the Jews with them.
They
get the mass grave dug,
and here we go.
Immediately.
Large numbers of Jews were
driven into the grave and the,
he always took their position on the
walls that had been thrown up. From there,
they shot the victims.
As the shooting continued,
the grave began to fill.
The Jews who followed,
had to climb on and later,
later even clamber over those shot
earlier because the grave was filled with
corpses almost to the edge.
The ncls decided that the execution
should continue with two firing squads on
opposite sides of the grave.
The Jews were forced to lie down
in rows alongside each other,
each side of the grave and were shot by
the police standing on the opposite wall.
Men from all three platoons were formed
into squads of eight to 10 and were
relieved by others in a rotation
after five or six shots.
After about two hours,
the he weaves were ry roused from their
stupor and resumed shooting in place
that Joe and policemen,
the shooting was finished around 7:00
PM and the work Jews who had been kept
aside covered the grave.
The work Jews were then shot as well.
The thin covering of the
overfill grave continued to move.
So you got people that are not dead,
that are now buried alive
and there was a part that I didn't cover.
Basically the,
he always got too drunk to continue on
and the the police had to go and take
their place for awhile and then they
kind of recovered. But this is this,
this is the situation
that we're talking about.
Just a complete nightmare
back to the book.
One other factor sharply distinguished
at low Mazi from Yosef wove and may well
have been yet another kind of
psychological relief for the men,
namely and this is important from from
a psychological and from a leadership
perspective.
One, so I'm going back through
to get one other factor.
Ma sharply distinguished low Mazi from
Yosef OEF and may well have been yet
another kind of psychological
relief for the men.
Namely this time they did not bear the
burden of choice that trap had offered
them so starkly on the
occasion of the first massacre.
No chance to step out
was given to those who did
not feel up to the shooting.
No one systematically excused.
Those who were visibly
too shaken to continue.
Everyone assigned to the firing
squad took his turn as ordered.
Therefore,
those who shot did not have to live with
clear awareness that they had what they
had done had been unavoidable.
So that's a big difference.
The big difference.
And from a leadership perspective,
that's something that I've,
I've actually talked about this before.
Um,
it's interesting. When we
were in Ramadi, you know,
we tasking at bruiser, we kind of
decided what we were going to do, right.
You know, we, we weren't
getting told go do this.
And so everything that we did,
we did because we decided that it was,
we could mitigate the risk and we could
take as good a good operation and we
could, there was an area that
we could do a good job in.
So we had a lot of control
over our fate and that's,
that's actually can be psychologically
heavier because if something goes wrong,
it's all, it's all on
you as the leader. Yeah.
Whereas the leadership team or even
as the guys that are on the front leg,
the point man, the point man
selecting his own, you know,
going down to the front row,
the frontline troops,
the point man is selecting the route.
If he hits an IED,
sure you know it's, it's
the enemy's fault. But,
but he's thinking to himself to why
did I choose that route? Now the army,
they did have some control but
they had more often than not,
they'd be getting told to,
hey you're going to go on a
patrol down this road or hey,
you're going to go hit this building.
So they were relieved oftentimes
have that freedom of choice.
Yeah. So the freedom of choice
can be a little bit of a burden.
And so what happened here was the
freedom of choice was taken away and that
burden was there for taking my look.
You're going to get shut up and do this.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
Cause you have like if you have that
choice like in back to the part where the
12 guys stepped up.
Right.
And Yeah,
we can look at it as the guys who
stepped out and have more courage because
they're are not essentially,
there's two things to be kind of scared
of or have courage against. Right. One is,
okay, I'm not scared to kill these
people. Pulled the trigger, you know,
and then there's, I'm not scared
to go against the norms. Yeah.
Which is bigger kind of thing
or much harder. Yeah. And that,
and you have the choice, which
one are you going to do? You know,
if they give you the choice, I'll
key, you can step out if you want.
What are you going to do? And
everyone's looking at you like, okay,
are you going to, I wonder
what the tipping point would
have been in other words,
like he chose to do it. No. If, if 10
people, but then what if it was 30? Yeah.
What if it was 40? And you see
that anytime in a crowd. Yeah.
You've seen that stupid, uh,
video where there's like one guy,
he's dancing by himself and it's,
it's like some viral videos that
kind of old school, I don't know,
but it's a stupid viral video. You
don't have to go and watch it yourself,
but I'll explain what happens. There's a
guy there like some kind of a concerts.
I'm kind of an outdoor concert.
There's a guy dancing by himself. Yeah.
He's dancing by himself for a
long time and that's why I saw it.
But his company was talking about
like group or they use this as an,
as an example of group psychology. The
guys dancing by himself for a long time.
And what they're actually saying is
that the person that has the courage is,
is actually the second person
that joins him. Uh, so anyways,
the one person dancing is dancing by
himself for several minutes. Yeah.
Then another port person joins him.
Once the other person joins him,
then all of a sudden five
people and then it's 20 people.
And then the next thing you know,
everyone is dancing.
And I wonder what the tipping point
would have been here. You know,
you get 10 people out of 500 that
wasn't enough. Yeah. But you know what?
If all of a sudden 15 2030 40
people would have stepped forward,
then all of a sudden does it just
everyone says, hey, we're not doing this.
Yeah. Yeah. I think if they knew,
I wonder if they knew for sure
that there wasn't going to,
cause some guys were getting called names.
Well yeah,
and I think it was the suddenness
that that he talked about in the book.
You know, if, if you'd have said, okay,
listen tomorrow. Yeah, we're going to do,
where do you want to kill a
bunch of women and children?
Point blank range in the woods. Yeah.
You're going to have to shoot them all.
Yeah. Let me know if you're down.
Yeah. And then if you had done that,
but then giving them hours to sit there
and think about it and then the next
guy's like, hey, what are you
going to do with it? Then the,
then it may have spread, but that
peer pressure was hardcore, hardcore,
so that, yes, especially with, like I
said, they're scared of the authority.
It's like, okay, the tipping
point is going to be more
for sure. But like, you know,
you do something like, you
know, your example or, or
year you ever see, you know,
you see this all the time
where you say you're on stage,
you say something kind of cool not,
you know,
it's not the end of your presentation.
You say something kind of cool and
then one guy starts clapping and then
everyone starts clapping. Right. You know,
it's kind of that thing where this is no
consequence to clapping. So it's like,
all right, oh shoot, that's what
we're doing. Okay. I, I all clap,
I feel good about clapping, I'm going
to do it, you know, kind of thing.
There's no real resistance. So the
tipping point is going to be one guy.
That's the tipping point. But you get
something where there's going to be,
there might be some resistance, some
risk, you know, of, of pain or you know,
whatever kind of punishment. Yeah. The
tipping point's going to be more, I think.
Yeah. I wonder what that is
man. Because it's not like,
like the Nazi regime was very
understanding. No, no, no,
no. I mean, no,
you know,
pretty much you can say that most
military units aren't very understanding.
Uh, you know, there's, there's going
to be a certain level of like Adt,
there's discipline in place for a
region reason and you can get, you know,
I talk about all the time,
you know, I said, look,
you can't just order people to do
things. It only lasts for so long. Yeah.
But how long did it need to last year?
It only needed the last night.
If you can get everyone to do what you
need them to do tonight, you know, we'll,
okay, we got through our
mission and now I'll let them,
you know, what did he do? He actually
let them go get drunk and you know,
talk to them and, and built up some more
leadership capital cause he expended,
he expended it a bunch of his leadership
capital to get this mission done and
now he's got to rebuild it and read,
kind of get developed this
relationship again with the guys and,
and bring in some other changes.
Hey look,
we're not gonna do all the killing
this time. So yeah, it's crazy. It's,
I thought it was pretty surprising and
I'd be kind of a few kind of cycle saying
refreshing to know that they
didn't get that much punishment
aside from some name calling. You know,
cause you don't think of it like that.
I think when you, when you think
of that like all this in it,
you know the guy you're saying you're
saying, yeah people, there you go. Yeah.
All that guy was named called.
Yeah.
And that's another thing that they proud
that that might've changed the tipping
point when they realized, you know,
that those guys have stepped forward.
They might've thought they get put
in the ditch because there are some,
and I didn't cover this part,
but there's,
there's definitely some
parts where guys like, Hey,
we'll put you in the ditch that's actually
get up here and do your job. Yeah,
but I think that reveals the
discomfort of the overall situation.
Yet they weren't looking at their buddy
saying, no, I'm going to kill you now.
They were like, Hey, we're
actually, I kind of agree with you,
but you just stay over
there and we'll go forward.
Okay.
So the next situation that they get
into are these deportations to Treblinka
death camp.
And here we go back to the book.
While the policeman did not know precisely
where the Jews were being sent or
what was being done with them,
it was all clear and well known to all
of us as Heinrich Steinmetz admitted that
for the Jews effected these
deportations meant the path to death.
We suspected that they would be
killed in some sort of camp spared.
Direct participation in the killing,
the men of Reserve Police
Battalion one-on-one seem
scary to have been disturbed
by this awareness.
Even though there were more victims in
the deportations than in Josefa or low
mousay massacres combined out
of sight was truly out of mind.
So now they're in this mode of
they're just doing the deportations.
Now I say just doing the deportations
and I don't want to make that sound like
it wasn't a brutal,
vicious exercise that they were doing.
Here we go back to the book driven
by the he always and policemen,
thousands of Jews steamed
into the marketplace, streamed
in the marketplace here.
They had to sit or squat
without moving or getting up.
As the hours passed on this very hot
August of the late summer heatwave,
many Jews
fainted and collapsed.
Moreover,
beating and shooting
continued in the marketplace,
and I don't know if I quoted this in here
or if I'll get to it, but these guys,
they, they're shooting people.
They also bring out whips,
so they're whipping people.
It's brutal. Back to the book.
One final horror was reserved
to the end for the train.
Cars now had to be loaded while the he
wheeze and security police packed 120 to
140 Jews into each car.
The reserve policemen stood guard and
observed as one remembered when it didn't
go well. They made use of
writing, whips and guns.
The loading was simply frightful.
There was an unearthly cry from these
poor people because 10 or 20 cars were
being loaded simultaneously. The entire
freight train was dreadfully long.
One could not see all of it.
It may have been 50 to 60 cars,
if not more.
And after a car was loaded,
the doors were closed and nailed shut.
Once all the cars were sealed,
the men of reserved police
battalion one-on-one quickly
departed without waiting
to see the train pull away.
These guys did their little part of the
job and they're gonna walk away now.
But
yeah,
it's, it's an, again,
it's a nightmare scenario.
Continuing on.
Shortly before the deportation program
resumed in northern security zone reserve
police battalion one-on-one was
involved in several more mass shootings.
So there's a couple of times that they
don't get the help that they had before
going back to the book without
the experience to help of the,
he always will haul off,
organize the executions
along the lines of Yosef,
of of the Osa folks shooting the groups
of 20 to 30 Jews which had been marched
out of town.
It's succession to gravel pits were turned
over to an equal number of Peter's in
year x commandos.
Thus,
each policemen once again faced the
individual Jew he was going to shoot.
The Jews were not forced to undress,
nor was there a collection of valuables.
There was also no selection for Labor.
All the Jews,
regardless of age and sex were to be shot.
So you know,
in the earlier ones they were stripping
him down and collecting their valuables
and not even doing that.
And I bet they're not doing
that because when you do that,
you're getting some kind of interaction.
You're seeing their personal items
and they didn't want any of that.
Just take them out and shoot him.
Easiest psychological way to do it.
Back to the book.
The policemen and the shooting commandos
marched their juice to the crest of one
of the mountains of waste material.
The area of the gravel pits,
the victims were lined up facing a six
foot drop from a short distance behind
the policemen fired on order
into the next of the Jews.
The body's tumbled over the
edge following each round.
The next group of Jews was brought up to
the same spot and thus had to look down
at the growing pile of corpses of their
family and friends before they were shot
in turn.
Only after a number of rounds
did the shooters change sites.
Okay.
All right. Here's some more
deportation operations.
They're back to doing
deportations back to the book,
but even the most unfettered violence
could not overcome the shortage of train
cars and when the doors were
finally forced, shot about 150 Jews,
mostly women and children,
but also some men remained made.
This was that same lieutenant sadist
summon Drucker and told him to take these
Jews to the cemetery.
At the cemetery entrance.
The policemen chased away the eager
spectators and waited until first Sergeant
Austin arrived in a truck with a
supply of vodka for the shooters.
Oschman turn to one of his men who had
hitherto avoided shooting and chided him
drink up.
Now Pfeiffer,
you're in fort this time because
the Judases must be shot.
You've gotten yourself out of it so far,
but now you must go to it.
An execution squad of about 20
men were sent into the cemetery.
The Jews were brought in groups of 20
men first and then women and children.
They were first to lie down
near the cemetery wall and
then shot from behind the
neck.
Each policemen fired seven or
eight times at the cemetery gate,
one do spring at Drucker with a syringe,
but was quickly subdued.
The other Jews sat quietly
awaiting their fate.
Even after the shooting began.
They were quite emaciated and
looked half starved to death.
One guard remembered.
Okay,
the it, it's, it's covered in here.
Not In the kind of detail
we should cover it, but
you know, these Jews that
were now getting rounded up,
they were already in most of the,
well in some of the case in the book,
they were in these
ghettos, Jewish ghettos, like they had
been forced into these ghettos there.
Now just living, they're
starving, but they're living and,
and then the Germans didn't, no
more Jews. They want of the areas,
I think the word was Juden free was like
free of Jews. So now even these people,
and by the way, there were some, some of
the Germans that complained like, Hey,
those are my laborers. You can't come
my laborers now we're killing everyone.
So even again,
it's not like this is
an enemy with a threat.
These people were now completely
subdued living in these,
in these call them guest ghettos.
They're like prison ghettos.
They're living in there. They've no
fret to anybody, but they round them up,
take them out and kill them.
Now,
one of the interesting points
that they bring up in the book,
and I want to cover the whole thing,
but it's worth mentioning,
is that this Guy Hoffman, one of the,
well it can, one of the captains,
he has this strange stomach illness
like he gets upset to his stomach,
so here we go.
He misses some of the actions,
or at least he's not their president
where the executions are taking place and
whatnot and it just painted a picture
of the kind of leader that he is.
So going back to the book uniformly,
Hoffman's men offered a
different perspective,
meaning it's not just like Yo,
he's sick to his stomach and blah,
blah blah. By their UBS observation,
his alleged bouts of stomach cramps,
confining him safely to bed coincided
all to consistently with company actions
that might involve either
unpleasantness or danger.
It became common for the men to predict
upon hearing the night before a pending
action that the company chief
would be bedridden in the morning.
Hoffman's behavior rankled as men even
more because of too aggravating factors.
First, he'd always been
strict and on approachable.
A typical base officer who liked his
white collar and gloves wore is ss in
Sydney on his uniform and demanded
considerable difference. So that's,
that's the one thing
you heard about the guy.
This is just paint the worst picture
of just such a horrible human being.
He loves wearing his rank. He loves
being the guy, a base officer.
Now there's, there's a, a
term for that. They have,
I think we made up in the,
not we,
but the US current war
fighting soldiers and marines.
It's a far bit Bob Fob.
So you get something called a forward
operating base overseas and the forwarding
on an operating basis can actually be,
you know, they're pretty nice there.
They're relatively secure.
And so the fob it right is the leader
that just wants to stay on the fob.
They didn't want to go out.
So this guys, but of course the fob,
it's always running around, you know,
wanting to be respected and demanding,
respect,
demanding deference of this guy's
a far bit. The other thing is,
and this is very typical of this kind
of wretched human back to the book.
Second Hoffman tried to compensate for
his immobility by intensified supervision
of his subordinates, so
he's not around, but he's,
he's going to be more of a jerk and impose
himself more onto the, onto the men.
Now they're continuing with a another,
another ghetto that had to be
cleared back to the book. By October,
the order was for real placards announced
that all Jews who did not go to the
ghettos would be shot.
The shooting order was made
part of regular company
instructions to the men and
given repeatedly, especially
before they were sent on patrol.
No one could be left in any doubt that
not a single Jew was to remain alive in
the battalion security zone.
In official jargon,
the battalion made forest patrols for
suspects as the surviving Jews were to be
tracked down and shot like animals.
However,
the men of reserved police battalion
one-on-one unofficially dub this phase of
the final solution.
The Jew hunt
that you hunt took many forms,
most spectacular or two battalion sweeps
and here's some George Leffler of
third company talking about that.
What those sweeps were
like back to the book.
We were told that there were
many Jews hiding in the forest.
We therefore searched through
the woods and a skirmish line,
but we could find nothing because
the Jews were obviously well hidden.
We combed the woods the second time.
Only then could we discover individual
chimney pipe sticking out of the earth.
We discovered that Jews had hidden
themselves in underground bunkers.
Here they were hauled out
with some resistance and
only one monk or some of the
comrades climbed down into this
bunker and hauled the Jews out.
The Jews were then shot on the spot.
The Jews had to lie face down on the
ground and were killed by a neck shot.
Who is in the firing squad?
I don't remember.
I think it was simply a case where the
men standing nearby were ordered to shoot
them.
Some 50 Jews were shot including men
and women of all ages because entire
families that hidden themselves,
they're
shooting took place quite publicly.
No cordon was formed at all for a
number of polls from [inaudible].
We're standing directly
by the shooting site.
They were then ordered
presumably by Hoffman
to bury the Jews who had been
shot in a half to finish bunker.
So again,
you've got some of the Jews
had been consolidated in
these ghettos and now there
anyone that's not any Jew, that's not
the ghetto, they're out hunting them.
Here's another version of it.
In cases where the farm yard and the
Jewish lodgings could be reached quickly,
I drove into the farm yard at high
speed and the police spring out in
immediately rushed to the Jewish
lodgings than all the Jews.
President at the time were driven out
and shot in the farm yard near a haystack
potato pit or dung heap.
The victims were almost always naked and
were shot in the neck where while lying
on the ground,
okay,
now,
even as this was taking place,
there's still people that are
trying to avoid the shooting.
Back to the book,
the tactic of keeping one's distance
was invoked by Heinrich Feucht
to explain how he avoided shooting on all,
but one occasion.
One always had a certain freedom
of movement of a few meters.
And from experience I noticed very quickly
that the platoon leader almost always
chose the people standing next to him.
I,
those always attempted to take position
as far as possible from the center of
events.
Others likewise sought to avoid
shooting by staying in the background.
So there's still guys that are not,
no,
they're trying,
they're doing their best
not to participate again or
they do anything to stop it.
No, but this, this was a
great kind of a wrap on the,
on the g one and what this was like
back to the book that you hunt was not a
brief episode.
It was a tenacious remorseless ongoing
campaign in which the hunters tracked
down and killed their prey in
direct and personal confrontation.
There was not a passing phase,
but an existential condition of constant
readiness and intention to kill every
last Jew who could be found.
Now we're good to cover this last
massacre
that took place.
And Jews had been sent
from a two to a prison camp to be
executed and and they were rounded up,
I think it was a place
called the lake lay back and
they were sent to be executed and the
police battalion is now acting as kind of
guards and accessories to this too,
to make sure that the executions,
these mass executions
take place correctly.
Going back to the book as
the pass between the chain
of reserve policemen into the camp music
blared from two loudspeaker trucks,
despite the attempt to
drown out other noise,
the sound of steady gunfire
could be heard from the camp.
The Jews were taken to the last row
of barracks where they undressed arms
raised, hands clasped behind
their next totally naked.
They were led in groups from the barracks
through a hole cut in the fence to the
trenches that had been
dug behind the camp.
This route was guarded by men from the
Reserve Police Battalion one-on-one
stationed only 10 meters from the graves.
Heinrich Boll cult of first company
witnessed the killing procedure quote.
From my position.
I could now observe how the Jews were
driven naked from the barracks by other
members of our battalion.
The shooters of the execution commandos
who sat on the edge of the graves
directly in front of me were members of
the SD and the SSD is like the SS Intel
Intelligence Group.
The SD,
some distance behind each shooter stood
several other SD men who constantly kept
the magazines of the submachine guns
filled and handed them to each shooter.
A number of shooters were
assigned to each grave.
Today I can no longer provide
details about the number of graves.
It is possible that there were many
such graves were shooting took place
simultaneously.
I definitely remember that the naked
Jews who are driven directly into the
graves and forced to lie
down quite precisely on top
of those who had been shot
before them,
the shooter than fired off a
burst at these prone victims.
How long the action lasted.
I can no longer say with certainty.
Presumably it lasted the
entire day because I remember
that I was relieved once
from my post.
I can give no details about
the number of victims,
but there were an awful lot of them.
It's it's,
it's almost incomprehensible to imagine
that you're one of these Jews getting
forced. You're naked. Lay
down, go into this pit,
lay down on top of those other people
that were just shot so you can be shot to
another witness.
Martin Detmold quote,
because I was a group leader in
could move about more freely.
I went once directly to the execution
site and saw how the newly arriving Jews
had to lie down on those already shot.
They were then likewise shot
with burst from submachine guns.
The SD men took care of that.
The Jews were shot in such a way that
there were inclines in the piles of
corpses enabling the newcomers to lie
down on the corpses piled as much as three
meters high.
The whole business was the most gruesome
I have ever seen in my life because I
was frequently able to see that after
a burst of a burst had been fired,
the Jews were only wounded
in those still living.
We're more or less buried alive beneath
the corpses of those shot later without
the wounded being given.
So called the mercy shots.
I remember that from out
of the pile of corpses.
The SS men were cursed by the wounded.
Yeah,
and that was sort of the final
participation of one on one battalion.
And here we get to there how it kind of
wrapped up at the conclusion of the ernt
fest massacres.
The district of Lublin was
for all practical purposes,
Utan free free of Jews,
the murderous participation of Reserve
Battalion Reserve Police Battalion One on
one in the final solution came to an end
with a conservative estimate of 6,500
Jewish shot during earlier actions like
those that Yosef Oaf and low Mazi and
1000 shot during the Jew hunts in a
minimum estimate of three thousand thirty
thousand five hundred juice shot
at [inaudible] and Pony Trois.
The battalion had participated in the
direct shooting deaths of at least 38,000
Jews
with the death camp deportation
of at least 3000 Jews from Mites,
Iraq.
In early May,
1943 the number of Jews they had
placed on trains to drew Blanka
had risen to 45,004 battalion
of less than 500 men.
The ultimate body count
was at least 83,000 Jews.
Yeah,
unbelievable.
And here he asked the question back to
the book of why did most men and reserve
police battalion one-on-one become killers
while only a minority of perhaps 10%
and certainly no more than 20% did not.
A number of explanations have been invoked
in the past to explain such behavior.
Wartime brutalization,
racism, segmentation,
and routinization of the task,
special selection of the perpetrators
careerism obedience to orders,
deference to authority,
ideological, Indra,
indoctrination and conformity.
These factors are applicable
in varying degrees,
but none without qualifications or
he's trying to now figure out why these
people did what they did.
And those,
that's a list of all the kinds of excuses
or reasons I should say of why these
men behave this way.
Talks a little bit about
overall kind of war crimes here.
Back to the book, many of the
most notorious wartime atrocities,
the Japanese rampage through Manila,
the American slaughter of prisoners and
mutilation of corpses on many of the
Pacific islands and the massacre at me
lie involved the kind of battlefield
frenzy soldiers who inert and who were
a nerd to violence numb to the taking of
human life.
They embittered over their own casualties
and frustrated by the tenacity of an
insidious and seemingly inhuman enemy
sometimes exploded and at other times
grimly resolved to have their
revenge at first opportunity.
So that's one type of,
for me,
what's that called when you like
non premeditated murder, right?
Like just,
you know the guy comes home and his wife's
with some other guy and boom, he goes,
he goes, battlefield frenzy.
Yeah. That's one kind.
Now we talk about this premeditated back
to the book, other kinds of atrocity,
lacking the immediacy of the battlefield
frenzy and fully expressing official
government policy decidedly
weren't standard operating
procedures firebombing of
German,
Japanese cities,
the enslavement of and murderous
maltreatment of foreign laborers in German
camps, in factories or
along the cm Burma Railroad,
the reprisal shooting of a 100 civilians
for every German soldier killed by
partisan attack and Unical Slavia
or elsewhere in eastern Europe.
These were not the spontaneous explosions
or cruel revenge of brutalized men,
but the methodical executed
policies of government.
Both kinds of atrocities occur in
the brutalizing context of war,
but the men who carry out
atrocity by policy aren't in
a different state of mind.
They act not out of frenzy,
bitterness and frustration,
but with calculation,
clearly the men of Reserve Police
Battalion One on one and implementing the
systematic Nazi policy of exterminating
European Jewry belong in the second
category
except for a few of the oldest men who
were veterans of World War One in a few
[inaudible] who had been transferred
from Poland to Poland from Russia.
The men in the battalion had not seen
battle or encountered a deadly enemy.
Most of them had not fired a shot in
anger or even been fired upon much less
lost comrades in fighting at their side.
Voss.
Wartime brutalization
through prior combat,
was not an immediate experience directly
influencing the policemen's behavior
add Yoseph of once the killing began.
However,
the men became increasingly
brutalized as in combat.
The horrors of initial of the initial
encounter eventually became routine and
the killing became premise
progressively easier
in a sense. In this sense,
brutalization was not the cause,
but the effect of the men's behavior.
So he's kind of saying, look
like what you said,
these guys aren't fighting an enemy.
They hadn't lost their buddy,
they're not revet. You know,
they're not avenging their buddy that got
killed next to them blown up by an IED
and now they're going to take it out on,
on this group that they capture.
And I like that
back to the book.
As John Dour has observed the
dehumanization of the other contributed
immeasurably to the psychological
distancing that facilitated killing,
distancing,
not frenzy.
And brutalization is one of the keys to
the behavior of the reserve position.
Police Battalion,
one-on-one war and negative racial
stereotyping or to mutually reinforcing
factors in this distancing.
So in order to kill these people,
you've got to distance yourself from them.
You can't, you can't see them as human.
You can't see them as people.
Many scholars of the Holocaust,
especially Raul Hilberg,
have emphasized the bureaucratic and
administrative aspects of the destruction
process.
This is very interesting.
This approach emphasizes the degree to
which modern bureaucratic life fosters a
functional and physical distancing in
the same way that war and negative racial
stereotype promote a psychological
distancing between perpetrator and victim.
So you formed this bureaucratic machine
that you're only a little piece of it.
Your all you're doing
is collecting people.
Are you doing just putting me on trains?
You're not killing anybody. Yeah, you're,
all you're doing is rounding them up.
All you're doing is guarding as
they're getting pushed down to the,
into the graves. That's
not you. Yeah. It's a big
bureaucratic machine. You're not,
you're just a little piece of
it. Back to the book. Indeed.
Many of the perpetrators of the Holocaust
were so called desk murderers who's
rolled in.
The mass extermination was greatly
facilitated by the bureaucratic nature of
their participation.
Their drops frequently consistent of
tiny steps in the overall killing process
and they performed them in routine manner,
never seeing the victims at their
actions affected segmented routine,
ISED and depersonalized the
job of the bureaucratic,
the bureaucratic or specialist,
whether it involved confiscating
scheduling trains, drafting legislation,
sending telegrams are compiling less
lists could be performed without
confronting them.
Reality of mass murder.
Such a luxury of course was not enjoyed
by the men of reserve police battalion,
one o one who were quite literally
saturated in the blood of victim shot at
point blank range.
No one confronted the reality of mass
murder more directly than the men in the
woods of Yosef of segmentation
and routinization.
The depersonalizing aspects
of the bureau bureaucratic,
the bureaucratic caused killing cannot
explain the battalions initial behavior
there. So again, he's saying,
look, that makes sense.
You turn this into a
big bureaucratic thing,
but that's not what happened
here with these guys.
The facilitating psychological effect
of a division of labor for the killing
process was not totally negligible.
However.
So then he talks about the fact that
they did make those adjustments and take
the killing out of their hands somewhat
and that did make it easier for
them. Now he talks about, you know,
one of the things that he mentioned
early on and why this happened.
He talks about the special
selection of the right people.
Well that doesn't really hold true either
because here we go back to the book.
The case for special selection of officers
is even more difficult to make by SS
standards.
Major trap was a patriotic German,
but traditionally and overly sentimental
what and not Nazi Germany was
scornfully considered
both weak and reactionary.
So you can't say it was
the selection of people.
And we already talked about all the
different types of normal people that were
doing this. They, they didn't,
they didn't pull some truck driver
in Hamburg out and said this,
that's 38 years old and say this guy's
going to be the perfect Miletich.
They didn't do that.
Back to the book reserve.
Police battalion was not sent to Lublin
to murder Jews because it was composed
of men specifically selected or dean
particularly suited for the task.
On the contrary,
the battalion was the dregs
of the manpower pool available
at that stage of war.
It was employed to kill Jews because it
was the only kind of unit available for
such behind the line duties.
Many studies of Nazi killer suggested
a different kind of selection,
namely self selection to the party and
the ss by an usually violence prone
people.
Shortly after the war,
Theodore Adorno and many others and
others developed the notion that there's
the, uh, an authority
authoritarian personality.
So they started looking at the,
there's certain people that have that,
that are susceptible to having
this type of personality.
They made up something called the f scale,
which is,
is like your propensity
to have a authoritarian
personality.
Here's some of the ingredients there.
Back to book of rigid adherence
to conventional values.
Submissiveness to authoritary
the to authority figures,
aggressiveness toward outgroups,
opposition to introspection,
reflection and creativity. A tendency
to superstition in stereotyping,
preoccupation with power and toughness.
Destructiveness and cynicism.
So these are the kinds of things that
they're saying that these types of
personalities would become Nazis because
that's the type of personality they
have.
There's another kind of kind of to
make this as simple as possible.
A guy named Zygmunt Bauman has summed
up the, this approach as follows.
Nazi-Ism was cruel because Nazis were
cruel and the Nazis were cruel because
crew people tended to become Nazis.
Again,
these are theories but I don't think you
can apply that to a truck driver from
Hamburg that got row that got drafted.
They didn't even sell self select for
they got drafted. Yup. Told, okay,
you need to be in the, in the army here.
Yeah, we're in the police battalion.
It's almost like, it's
not necessarily, you know,
a person being a truck driver
is like, uh, you know this,
this exclusionary occupation.
It's more like just cause they're a truck
driver. It just doesn't mean anything.
It's like that's not enough factor. The
truck driver. Now anything with Eddie,
when they talked about all
these people from Hamburg,
anything that they talked about,
none of those.
It's not like we got a
bunch of guys that were uh,
that worked at a slaughter
house. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to recruit all these
people from a slaughterhouse. No,
we didn't recruit hunters. We didn't
know. They didn't recruit, um,
football players because
they're aggressive. No, just
rate. It was just random.
Any job.
And they showed up there.
So we know basically what I'm getting
out of this is he saying like, no,
it's like you can't really
say it's that either. Right?
Because it's just a
waiter in a salesperson.
But at the same time the guy who is a
waiter could have these other qualities,
you know, like how you're talking. Yeah.
But you take 500 people from Hamburg
between the ages of 35 and 40.
You're not going to find that.
It's like all these guys had those kind
of fascist qualities boundman right.
Not Happening. Yeah, man. That's great.
Some people become,
this is Eric or sorry.
Evan Staab accepts the notion that some
people become perpetrators as a result
of their personality.
They are self selected and he says
that under particular circumstances,
most people have a capacity for extreme
violence and the destruction of human
life.
It's an interesting one.
Under certain circumstances,
everyone has a propensity for violence.
I'm sure there's that would argue that in
all different directions. But you know,
you take a
a middle aged woman that's never been
in a fistfight before and you have
somebody attack her child that's going
to kill or harm their child and they can
see it propensity for violence and
from a lot of them. Yeah, yeah.
Maybe even a v You know what?
99%,
I'm going to say 99% I'll go with
that too. Yeah. Yeah. 99% if you're,
if it's a middle aged woman who has
someone that's about to severely hurt or
kill their child and their way to
stop it is with a pistol. Right.
My assessment is we're going to 99%.
Yeah. Of that perpetrators
getting guild like with,
with um,
specific
effort towards like the violent part of
it. You know, like, um, you know, I don't,
I'm not saying not a movie necessarily,
but you know, that'll think,
well let's say imagine a scenario like
that where the lady's gonna shoot this
guy because the guy is attacking the
kid or something. It won't be like, Oh,
let me do the bare minimum force,
you know,
dish to eliminate the threat.
She's probably going to be kind of shows
the overboard killing that guy going to
kill him extra. Yeah. Yeah.
Because that's kind of the
violence coming out of someone.
It's one thing to do it because
I'm scared and oh my gosh,
get away from me kind of thing.
That's not violence. Yeah. So it's,
that's really the question when you
consider a million middle aged girl,
you know?
Yeah. Having a propensity provider, I
don't think she's going to do extra.
I think she's going to kill him and go
and go grab her kid and make sure a kid
safe. Right. I don't see
this extra level, you know,
desecration of the body or anything
like that. I just say, Hey,
I'm going to say make my kids safe.
Yeah.
So you're saying the propensity for
violence in that case is just the mere act
of killing the guy. Yeah. Well
yeah, that's that's, that's it.
Yeah. You know, like
I'm thinking of a movie,
whatever reason, cause that's all,
that's all your brain is filled with
television in general. But you
know, the girl, she's like scared.
It's all done out of
fear, you know? And sure.
It's almost like the violence
is just happenstance.
It's not her propensity for violence
necessarily, but it's just the money.
But I'm just saying if you
set up an experiment yes.
Where you took a middle aged
group of women had children. Yeah.
Like when you put them in a scenario
where, you know, w was either the,
either the kid dies or they
kill the perpetrator. Right.
You know, not like a, hey,
I might be able to debate them out of it.
Know that the ax is in the air.
It's going to be swung down
on the kid. Right, right.
You have to press this button to go
to kill that guy. We're violence.
Violence is a choice. Yeah. I think
the prevents that. He's going to be 99,
and yeah, I'm going to
go even higher. Agree.
So this then he gets into,
um,
some of these real experiments,
kind of sociological experiments.
One of them is the Zimbardo's
Stanford prison experiment.
I'm sure you've heard of that.
Everyone's heard of that
where they basically take
people and divide them up and
just randomly,
and actually I didn't know this cause I
never did any deep research on the study,
but they kind of do a prescreening
to make sure that there's no extreme
personalities. Everyone that
everyone knows. Like, I mean
what, however you could,
you could frame the word normal.
The people that participate in the
experiment or just like normal people,
they didn't have any
extreme personalities.
Well those kind of semi normal people,
they put them in that prison experiment.
And sure enough,
some people were made guards,
some people were made prisoners and they
had to get him to do certain things.
And there's a certain number.
I mean it didn't take long for the guards.
I think it took six days. Some of
the guards turn sadistic evil. Right?
Uh, and here we go back to the book most
dramatic and distressing to us was the
observation of the ease with which
sadistic behavior could be elicited in
individuals who are not sadistic types.
The prison situation alone,
Zimbardo concluded was a sufficient
condition to produce apparent antisocial
behavior.
That's from the gardens from the guards.
So this is pretty scary that another fact
here pointed out about that only to I
less than 20% emerged as good guards who
did not punish prisoners even as they
end even did small favor from.
So those numbers are pretty in line with
this really small percentage of people
that just, they're just
good people, right?
It's only 10 to 20% of actual good people.
How's that make you feel about
the human race and not real good?
Not real good.
All right.
Another thing put out here, back to the
book, among the perpetrators, of course,
orders have traditionally been most
frequently cited explanation for their own
behavior. So remember orders, orders,
orders were orders and no one in such
a political climate could be expected.
Disobey them. They insisted this is
the, this is the guards. I mean, sorry,
this is the the police to
battalion saying, look,
we're getting order to do the stuff
we were just following orders.
We hear that all the time.
Disobedience surely meant
the concentration camp if
not immediate execution
possibly for their families as well.
So they're saying, look, if we would,
we would ended up in the concentration
camps ourselves if this didn't happen.
Now he pointed this out back to the book.
There is a general problem
with this explanation. However,
quite simply in the past 45 years,
no defense attorney or defendant in any
of the hundreds of postwar trials has
been able to document a single case in
which refusal to obey an order to kill on
armed civilians resulted in the
allegedly inevitable Dyer punishment.
So no precedent for that. Now I, I,
I don't think that these guys out there
in the battalion are sitting there
thinking about this with like legal
perspectives. So actually there,
there's no precedent for,
you know,
punishment being carried out
on people that have been on.
I think that's a stretch.
I think that's a stretch when you're
talking about like maybe someone
contemplating using these guys that
were saying I couldn't refuse the orders
cause I would get punished.
And he's saying that there's no precedent
that you actually will get the severe
punishment.
But how has the,
you know when someone out in the
field going to know that that's a,
that's a precedent. You don't,
you just think I don't want
to get in trouble. Yeah.
You're not thinking about the time you
remember the guy that you've heard of
getting killed. Yeah. You're not
thinking of that. You're thinking about,
you're not even more so you're not
thinking about the fact that you've never
heard of that before.
[inaudible] all right. Now,
so we're talking about obedience of
orders and here we go back to the book.
A full obedience to orders out of
fear of dire punishment is not a valid
explanation.
What about obedience to authority in
the more general sense used by Stanley
Milgrim deference simply as a product
of socialization and evolution,
a deeply ingrained behavior tendency
to comply with the directives of those
positioned hierarchically above them.
Even to the point of performing repugnant
actions in violation of universally
accepted moral norms. So you've
heard of the Milgram experiments?
No. No, these are, these are kind of
like the Stanford prison, pretty famous.
And what he did was he set up
these experiments where he had,
you could see these
actors were behind a wall,
but they were getting asked questions.
And the the,
if they answered the question wrong,
they would get a little electric shock
that was done by the person that was
being experimented on. So, you know,
I would be, they'd say, okay Jocko,
you've got this guy, his name
is echo, he's over there.
We're going to ask them a question.
If he gets it wrong,
you hit him with the shock. I
can't see you, but I can hear you.
So when I shock you and,
and every question that you get wrong,
I have to escalate the level of shock.
So it's getting worse and
worse and worse and worse.
And your reaction is more and more
horrific as these things escalate.
But you're the guy, the experiment,
the experiment is on me. No,
you're just knocked it. There's no
ratchet, we'll shock. Okay, Gotcha. So,
and you're actually going through
a series of complaints and I'll,
I'll,
I'll read this here.
There was an escalating series of fake
electric shocks upon a Vic act or victim
who responded with carefully programmed
voice feedback on escalating series of
complaints, cries of pain, call for help.
And finally,
fateful silence.
In the standard voice feedback experiment,
two thirds of Milgram's subjects were
obedient to the point of inflicting
extreme pain.
Several variations on the experiment
produce significantly different results.
If the actor slash victim was shielded
so that this subject could hear and see
no response.
Obedience Muslim was much greater.
So if I couldn't hear you and I just
knew that I was shocking the hell out of
you,
I was good with it.
If the subject had both
visual and voice feedback,
compliance fell to the
compliance to the extreme,
fell to 40% so down from 66% to 40% if
the subject had had to touch the actor
slash victim physically by forcing his
hand onto an electric plate to deliver
the shocks, obedience
dropped at 30%. Now this is,
this is fascinating.
If a non authority figure gave orders,
obedience was nil. So if
some guy was like, hey,
you know, am bill, I'm running the
experiment, um, hey, shock this guy.
If the guy was no authority, the
they got no, they got no, none,
no obedience. So that shows you, and
that's from a leadership perspective,
that's very important to understand.
It's important to understand how much
influence you have when you're in a
leadership position.
And I run in this all the time and I
ran into and they seal teams when a guy
doesn't recognize the power of his rank
and he doesn't recognize that just by
wearing his rank. When he says something,
people kind of like going to do it,
they're good to go.
Well they want to do it.
So then going back to the book here,
if the naive subject performed a
subsidiary or accessory task but did not
personally inflict the electric shocks,
obedience was nearly total.
So that goes down to the
division of Labor. Again, if
it was just me saying, okay,
I asked him a question,
you'd have to shock him again and
some other guy was shocking you,
I'd go straight to a hundred
straight to you all hundred.
In contrast,
if the subject or pure was part of an,
if the subject was part of an act or
pure group that staged carefully planned
refusal to continue to follow
directions of the authority figure,
the vast majority of subjects,
90% joined their peer group
and desist and desist as well.
So that's the tipping point thing.
If there was other, so if it was,
if it was three of us that were conducting
the experiment on you and the other,
I was the, the the naive guy that
doesn't know what's going on.
I'm the one that they were
actually doing the experiment on
and there's two guys,
two actors that are in the room with me,
and they're going to be like, hey
man, we shouldn't be doing this,
and the other guy goes, yeah man,
that looks like it's really hurting,
but we should stop this. 90% of the
time I go, yeah, you guys are right.
Psychology group psychology.
If the subject was given
complete discretion as to
the level of electric shock
to administer all but a
few sadists consistently
delivered a minimal shock when
not under direct surveillance
of the scientist.
Many of the subjects cheated by
giving lower shocks than prescribed,
even though they were unable to confront
authority and abandon the experiments.
So they'd give lower shelves,
but they wouldn't walk away from it.
They wouldn't just say, I'm
not going to do this. Yeah.
It took her through their phones.
Re Really? You know what it is.
We're all just on the
edge, man. In a way. Yeah,
and we kind of need each other in that
way to wellness. It's, again, this is,
you know,
this is about leadership.
It's amazing how influential or
how influenceable people are.
They're so ready for influence are
so ready to be told like, hey man,
we shouldn't be doing this.
It's the same thing we saw with the,
with the podcast on the meal,
I'm asker.
All it took was one officer saying stop
killing and everyone, okay, stop killing.
Right. Everyone just, they just need
to get nudged in that direction.
And by the way, they had already
been nudged in the other direction,
which is kill everyone. And they
said, all right, cool. We'll go out.
And that's what I mean by on the,
I don't mean on the edge
of like sanding nothing.
I mean on the fence you're on the fence.
That's why leadership is so important
because you are walking around with people
all over the world and,
and whatever position you're in,
regardless if it's in a work environment,
if it's a social environment,
if it's with your friend
or your peer group,
you have so much power over people just
by being a leader and by using that
influence to work people one way or the
other. Yeah, that's crazy, man. Yeah.
It is crazy.
Going back to the book to what were the
vast majority of traps men responding to
when they did not step out?
Was it the authority as represented
by either trap or his superiors?
Were they responding to trap?
Not primarily as an authority figure,
but as an individual,
a popular and beloved officer who they
Missumi who they would not leave in the
lurch.
What about other factors?
Milgrom himself notes that far that people
far more frequently invoke a 40 then
conformity to explain their
behavior for the only,
the former seems to absolve
them of personal responsibility
and he quotes here.
Subjects denied conformity and embrace
obedience as the explanation of their
actions, so people don't like to say
everyone else is doing it, so I get it.
People don't like to say
that because that, that,
that means I'm responsible for it. People
don't like to take ownership of things.
It's probably have a book
called extreme ownership.
People don't like to take ownership of
things, right? Instead, they want to say,
as soon as I blame something on my
Boston, this is one of the, you know,
big things in extreme ownership
leading up the chain of command.
It's so easy to blame your boss
because how can I control my boss?
I was following, I was following
orders, Boston way to do this.
That's why we failed the mission.
I was told to do this mean he didn't
give me the right gear. That's,
we hear this all the time and,
and, and Milgrom says it too.
No one wants to say, Hey, you know what?
I decided I was just going to
do what everyone else was doing.
That's my decision. Instead, they put that
decision on the other guy on the boss,
man.
Yup.
Another exploration here,
back to the book,
direct proximity to the horror of killing
significantly increased the number of
men who would no longer comply.
On the other hand,
with the division of labor and removal of
the killing process to the death camps,
the men felt scarcely any responsibility
to offer for their actions. Same thing.
MILGROM figured out. No,
I got someone else that's
pressing the button over there.
The shocking you. I'm good
with it. Yeah. Keep Rolling.
Now, one thing that Milgrom
kinda talks about is his,
the kind of indoctrination
or what kind of,
what kind of ideological justification
did he give to his people?
It's really just preexisting
in Milgram's experiment.
These are just kind of normal people.
So what about with the Nazis and what
kind of indoctrination did they get?
Brainwashed,
right.
We have talked about this a little
bit already, but back to the book,
all order police battalions were to be
strengthened in character and ideology.
One topic for the first week, they went
through like a school and education,
ideological education.
One topic for the first week was race as
the basis of our worldview followed by
the second week maintaining
the purity of blood.
So there you go.
These guys are being indoctrinated.
But the reason that that argument doesn't
really hold much weight is because of
the way who the people were.
And back to the book,
whatever the merits of such an argument,
it clearly does not hold
for the predominantly middle
aged men of reserve with
leap police battalion one on one.
They were,
they were educated and spent their
formative years in the pre 1933 period.
Many came from a social may,
Lou that was relatively
unreceptive to national socialism.
They were,
they knew perfectly well the moral
norms of German society before the Nazi.
So you can't really blame it
on them being brainwashed.
So
here's how,
here's how a browning wraps up this book.
I'm going to close it out.
The behavior of any human being is
of course a very complex phenomenon.
And the historian who attempts to explain
it is indulging in a certain arrogance
when nearly 500 men are involved to
undertake any general explanation of their
collective behavior is
even more hazardous.
What then is one to conclude,
most of all,
one comes away from the story of Reserve
Police Battalion One on one with a
great unease.
This story of ordinary men
is not the story of all men.
The reserve policemen faced choices and
most of them committed terrible deeds,
but those who killed cannot be absolved
by the notion that anyone in the same
situation would have done as
they did for even among them.
Some refuse to kill and others stopped.
Killing
human responsibility is
ultimately an individual matter.
At the same time,
however,
the collective behavior of Reserve
Police Battalion One o one has deeply
disturbing implications.
There are many societies afflicted by
traditions of racism and caught in the
siege mentality of war or Fred of war
everywhere society conditions,
people to respect and defer to authority
and indeed could scarcely function
otherwise everywhere people
seek career advancement
in every modern society.
The complexity of life and the resulting
bureaucratic ization and specialization
attenuate the sense of
personal responsibility of
those implementing official
policy
within virtually every social collective.
That peer group exerts
tremendous pressures on
behavior and sets moral norms.
If the men of Reserve Police Battalion
One on one could become killers under
such circumstances,
what group of men cannot
and there you have it and
I think those are some
extremely important warnings
that are laid out there.
I mean, obviously the first
one, we have to be aware of
traditions of racism
and the threat of war,
and I think those are pretty obvious
and stand out pretty clearly. Yeah.
I think the other ones are a
little bit trickier, right?
I think we've got to watch out
for the fact that we are conditioned
to respect and defer to authority.
I say to that, no, and I actually,
you know, I, when I grew up,
I was a rebellious kid and I listened to
rebellious music and I was a rebellious
kid.
I talk about that and I think that was
very beneficial for me in my military
career
and explained that all the
time that I asked questions.
If I don't believe in something, I'm
going to ask questions. And by the way,
I don't, I want the people
that work for me or with me.
I want them to ask questions to,
I don't want to be surrounded by yes
men and I'm not going to be yes ma'am.
Never was. Nope, I haven't met.
Let me, let me caveat that.
Not that I never was because
sometimes you've got to be a yes man.
In order to get the inner circle
where you can actually have influence.
So have I played that game before?
Yes, I have. Yeah. Yeah. Boss.
That sounds like a good plan. Yeah. Boss
yet that says good plan. Oh I trust Jocko.
He agrees with me all the time. Hey boss,
you're going off the rails over here.
He stop it. Oh I'm going to listen
to Jocko cause he listens to me.
So have I played that game
before? Yes, of course I have.
So we need to be careful that we
don't submit always to authority.
It's a hard thing to raise your
kids with too. Right? Cause you,
cause you want your kids to submit to your
authority, but you don't want them to,
yeah. I have to always remind
myself when they rebel against me,
I have to say to myself,
good.
Because I want them to ask questions.
I want them to question authority.
I don't want them to just obey.
Right. Yeah. And it freaks people out.
It freaks people out when
you say w w you know,
I'll go and work with a company and I'll
be saying like, no, I want your people.
You want your people to ask questions.
If you want to just order them around
and they're just going to obey you,
first of all,
I'm not going to help you there because
that's not a system that's functional.
It will be functional for a week.
It'd be functional for two weeks,
but eventually you will have people that
don't understand why they're doing what
they're doing.
They don't put their effort to and they
can't make decisions on their own and
you end up with a bad team.
Yeah.
We don't want that kind of authoritarian
leadership anywhere and certainly not,
not, not anywhere. Again, does it work for
five minutes? Does it work for week? Yeah,
it does.
Is it sometimes needed because people
gotta we gotta get something done right
now.
Yeah,
but you better follow that up with
some non authoritarian leadership with,
with explaining and building
relationships with people. Yeah.
That ex explanation thing that you
guys didn't talk about all the time.
We're explaining why.
Explain why I'm telling you to do this.
It's important because
of this x, Y, Z man. It,
and I'm speaking from a
perspective of being a parent,
how effective that is. You just
say, this is why you're doing it.
That's effectively how old is your
daughter now it's already affected with a
four year old. Yeah. And even maybe some
mornings you can always rationalize it.
A four year old. Sometimes they just want
that cookie careers. Know why about it?
It was strangely with the, um, we, we
have a situation right now where I'm,
her cousin is in and um,
you know,
he put in a nutshell, his
diet isn't quite it. Um,
as she's not on the, but he's not
on the program, on the program,
like how my daughter is program,
but you know,
he'll eat junk food or whatever. Right.
And it's kind of part of the experience.
I understand where,
you know,
hey cousins in from out of town and
it's a little bit more festive. Yeah.
So after awhile I started realizing like,
cousin show up at my house and getting
on the program. It should be like that.
So after awhile I was like,
Hey, the, you know, we just,
there's too many treats going
on these days, you know,
for the psycho had to drop the
head to intervene a little bit.
And so when I told my daughter,
I was like, no, you know,
we're not going to do this. And I
explained why you could tell she didn't,
she wasn't happy with it, but she
totally understood four years old where,
and I did it in a way where it wasn't
like you referenced way of the Warrior Kid
always. Dude, she was wearing that
shirt to school today too, by the way.
Coincidentally when right. They're
using millennia. But um, it was,
it w I didn't scare her. You
no idea. I wasn't like, Ooh,
then you're going to be a loser or
something. You know, something like that.
My kids say to each other,
oh,
you might as well just go out and
volunteer for type two diabetes.
They get crazy and they
learn that from, yeah. Yeah,
I know exactly where they learned,
but it was just the kind, you know,
like where the older kids do it.
To my younger daughter,
you're going to get type two
diabetes on the peer pressure.
She thinks she's going to get it
today. Yeah. That's messed up.
You know it is most effective
or ineffective though,
right? That's your thing.
No, but anyway, the point being it is,
it is effective. Especially, I mean, yet,
you know like how you say to,
you don't have to be a dick about it.
It's not a scolding. It's not nothing
like that. Yeah. It's cool on explanation.
Actually understanding contrary to that,
it's the other end of the spectrum. Yeah.
Yeah. We're using, I'm talking to you
is because I care about you so much,
but I want you to be healthy. Yeah.
That's the only reason I'm talking to you.
You ever get like your parents say that?
Say those exact words.
I do this because I care about you.
Meanwhile,
they're yelling at you versus banking.
You employers do it.
Two bosses do that too. Yeah, no.
The first thing they do is I want to
jump down someone's throat and then
everyone's reactions to the same to that.
Yeah. One likes it. No one likes it.
Whereas if you take a different
approach and you say, Hey, echo,
do you know why I'm talking to you right
now? It's not because I'm mad at you.
Right. It's because I'm actually, I
see nothing but potential with you.
That's what I see. And when I,
when I see that you're not making,
you're not making many videos. It's not,
it's not, cause I'm, I'm thinking myself,
oh,
I want more videos.
The reason I'm thinking it's because I
actually see how much potential you have
and you could really do some powerful
stuff and have some huge influence Tang,
but you're still right, Jocko. So. Right.
As opposed to you better make more videos.
Yeah.
Or else I'm going to have my kid do it.
We'd be lazy. Exactly. Then you'd
be like, fine, I it could do it.
They won't be as good as mine. She
was saying. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So that's not what we wanted. That's
not the game we're playing here. Yeah.
I do see a lot of potential in you then.
I think you could make more videos.
Thank you so much.
So
you gotta Watch out for Oh,
being a 40 you've got to question
authority all the time and you've,
then he talks about people
seeking career advancement.
That was another big one and this is
another big one I say no to right.
There's such a much better way to get
career advancement and that is by doing a
good job.
Yeah.
That's how you get career advancement by
instead of seeking career advancement,
seeks, do good job, seek to make a
difference to seek to do what is right.
The career is going to come in one form
or the other. Now my you get passed up.
Might some other guy that tooted
his own horn and took the credit,
might that happen? Yes, it might happen.
You might, you might get delayed,
but that guy is going to continue to
build that reputation and they're,
the bosses missed it on the first
round of advancements. So he got it.
Maybe even gets the second
round by the third round.
They're looking at him going,
this guy has a self serving loser.
We need to get them off the team.
And by the way,
we realized that the guy that's been
behind all his work is echo over there,
so we're going to promote him now.
Now you're going to win.
Now you've got a really solid reputation.
You'll broke so you can't. But the, the,
the idea of seeking career advancement,
you see that in the military all the time.
There's people that are just trying to
get advanced, trying to get advanced,
trying to get, don't cares who's backed
or stepping on, and I'm telling you,
I said,
I saw some of those guys get advanced in,
in my community that advanced
up through the ranks.
They were stepping on
people's backs to get there.
The reputation eventually was so
bad that it didn't get them propel.
They didn't propel as far as
they want it to look. Great guys,
the guys that were really truly just
trying to do the best for the community,
those guys got promoted and
aid would make it, you know,
the furthest because their reputation
was so solid and everyone knew that these
guys were doing the right
things for the right reason,
not so they could get promoted, but they
ended up getting promoted. Yeah. Yeah.
Promotion is more for like a, like
an eventuality. Eventuality. Yeah.
It's just like Jujitsu.
If you're just trying to get your belt
and that's what you're trying to prove,
that's not gonna work out well for you.
Getting mad when the,
the game like emoted you might get your
blue belt before some other white belt
because you're showing off all the time,
but eventually you're showing off all
the time and the coach goes, hey man,
why don't you help everyone? Or
the coach goes, Hey, I see you.
I see you're tapping a lot of people out
that are the same level as you all the
time, but you're not going with
anyone that's harder than you.
Cause you wanna prove to me that you're
tapping and went out and long move.
You know what you might see
sometimes it's, you know,
like you know when you come up through
the Jujitsu ranks you, you, you just,
you just find a certain mood
move or handful of moves
and you just, those moves,
you get better. I'm still there. Yeah.
I think we all kind of are in one
way or another. And so this is,
this is what,
if you're pursuing the belt is what you
do on instructors around only do your
good moods. Do you want to look
good? Yeah. You want to look good.
That's all you do. You know, and you did.
And when you say it will show
itself later, you know, so what you,
what can happen is you get your blue belt,
you get your purple belt.
Cause like you show off to your
instructors or whatever the tournaments to
realize. I just realized something about
myself. I just had a rude awakening.
Huh. But what will happen is
later on you ever get, okay.
So this might be, it might have been a
long time for you, but maybe not. So,
okay. So I'm taking, I'm
training with, uh, in, Oh,
I'm sorry.
I went to class.
Jeff Glover is teaching the class and
Jeff Glover was like, Hey, let's do this.
And he does some crazy
kind of advanced move,
but it takes like if you're an advanced
person, you know how to, you know,
how to move your body in Jujitsu
kind of in an advanced way.
You can do the move even though you've
never done the movie before. You know,
that kind of went.
So was that kind of movie was one where
you got to like go between the guy's
legs, lift up into he'll hook or
whatever, like locked you choose.
So I don't do that move at all.
And I've been training,
I've been in this game for a long time,
so I go and I do it and not,
I don't want to say I was surprised,
but like I could do it. I can totally.
But Jeff was like, oh, kind of like Dang,
cause I'm a bigger guy too, you know?
And that made me think of this
kind of thing where some guys,
they can be a black belt
and they'll say, hey, hey,
show this move real quick
and it'll be a black man.
They can't do it because
they've avoided that.
And not to say that this
is the case all the time.
I'm just saying that's like an example
of how you can avoid getting better and
only show off like x,
Y,
Z to get you to that kind of next
specific level. Yeah. I don't,
new belt or whatever is
a similar thing maybe.
But I realized when you
were talking about this,
what I'll do is both
with Jean and with Jeff,
if I do, if I'm doing something
that they showed me, I'll like,
I'll like call them out like a
little kid. I'll be like, yeah,
I'd be like, oh you like that one.
That New Orleans, I do it with Dean,
with my kids when my kids are training,
you know,
I'll say 18 dean, check, look at that,
look at that. He's going to get it.
You know what I mean?
Of like all happy. Yeah.
I'm just happy that I'm learning
or that they're learning.
It's pretty cool when you can pull off
what you just learned. Right? Yeah.
That's cool. And it's cool for
a teacher. I always, I'm still,
when somebody does something
that I showed them big time.
So I guess the differences if in fact
this isn't even the difference, um,
is why did you do that?
It's not to get your kid promoted to get
me promoted cause I can't get you kind
of can't get promoted right
now. Yeah. So I guess,
I guess it's sort of like maybe,
maybe,
maybe the negative aspect would be like
I'm looking for some credit for calling
off of the little guy move totally
differently. No, I don't think it's,
I think it's pretty bad. I liked it.
I think I'm pretty lame for that.
Um, yeah. So watch out for that.
Watch out for their career advancement.
Don't let that be the folks, your life,
man. It's God's not going to make you,
it's not going to get you what you want.
Now again,
are there instances where you play the
game so that you can move up so that you
can have more control? Yes,
I did that. I look, I be,
I went from enlisted to officer.
That's the ultimate in, Hey,
I'm going to play the game. I'm
going to get more. I want to,
I want to be in charge of more stuff.
So how am I going to do that?
I'm going to be, I'm going to skip all
these ranks. Become an officer. I did
that. Yeah. I played that
game. I was about my career,
but I was about my career
so I could make you know,
15 guys in a seal platoon happy.
Yeah.
Cause I was happy when I had a
good leader in my seal platoon. Um,
the other one he talks about here
is this bureaucrat as a nation and
specialization attenuating the
sense of personal responsibility.
This is another thing that
we have to be careful of.
Just because you're part of a
system doesn't mean you should just,
you know, blame the system when
something goes wrong. You know,
if you're working somewhere
and something isn't going, hey,
that's the way we do it. Hey, that's
the way the system works. Hey,
we can't change that.
And I never accepted that as an answer.
And I'll tell you what,
when you come up against that,
you can't eat the way you fight it
when you come up against as you build a
relationship. Right. So any you ever,
you ever have a,
you're trying to deal with some customer
service or something and you're getting
that, sorry, we can't help you. Yeah. And
you go down to the store and like, Hey,
what's going on? Hey Bill, I am Jocko
man. I called you earlier. I just,
I got to get this thing resolved.
Here's what's going on. You don't,
you don't go down there and say you
need to take care of this. No. You say,
hey bill, what's going on?
Hey, I'm Jocko. Yeah man.
I really liked the piece of
gear, but man, it worked good.
There was a couple issues I have with
everyone trying to get them resolved
because you know, my daughter's
birthday's in two weeks and I need them.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
Former relationship with them.
Let's get the bureaucratic, don't let them
stay in their big bureaucratic system.
Yeah. We don't want to let
that happen because then the,
then the bureaucratic machine,
then they're, they're not,
they're not the ones that are
offending you. It's the machine.
They can't control the machine.
It's not their machine.
There's part of the machine.
Right.
You want to you and where this concept
fundamentally is the same as this,
you know, when you're in
traffic, you know, and you're
trying to get over kind of,
yeah, yeah, yeah. And you want to
get into the lane, but you know,
from the other guy's perspective
or the other car's perspective,
this car is trying to cut me off this car.
This car's going to get in my way.
Right. But you get your,
whoever you're riding with,
all you gotta do to get
them rolled down the window,
make eye contact with a person and be
like, Hey, just wave at them or something.
Look, I'm a person. You're a person. We're
not standing in line. What else? Any,
like we're just, we're hoping the themes,
we're not machines, we're not much.
You can just give them the
hint of a personal element.
Let you right in the wave.
You in, you weight back. You
guys are friends that and before,
keeping in mind two seconds before that
you were pissed. Yeah. They're like,
discuss the plot to get in front of me.
And there's no reason to be
mad about that, by the way.
It's not like you're sitting
in some way to get there.
He's gotta be some more to the
same direction in the rush. Yeah,
but you got to put it on your deal. Same
thing. Step out of the machine, man.
The machine of trust. Step out.
Hey, I'm a person. You're a person.
Make the personal relationships up and
down the chain of command throughout your
company. Don't let the, don't let
the finance department, right? Yeah.
The department, the finance department
is shot us down on this thing. Yeah.
Give me the name. Who did that? I'm
going to walk down there and Tim,
I'll see what the marketing department
won't give us any more than, okay, cool.
Let's find out who that is.
That's not a bureaucratic maze.
It's not a marketing department
machine. No, it's bill.
Bill's in there 100% when bill
knows what you're trying to do,
I noticed that you are trying
to make something happen.
You make that connection and we're good
to go. Bill is going to take care of you.
I don't even no reason to freak out.
The other thing,
finally here is this,
this idea of this peer group,
this social collective,
pure pressure.
We all know it exists and that's fine,
but make it good,
right?
Peer pressure is powerful.
It's powerful and the good thing is you
get to control it in both directions.
You need to recognize it when it's
happened to you in a negative way and then
you need to use it
in a positive way to help people do
good things. Jews, peer pressure,
peer pressure is legit for
making people do positive things.
What you don't want to do is use peer
pressure to make people do negative things
and there's a lot of that in the world.
Then I'll tell you why.
There's a certain part of people that
don't like to see other people succeed.
Yeah. So they go, man, just
come out tonight dude. But dude,
I kind of work in the
morning to just come out,
which is going to get a couple of drinks.
Here's another one. Let's do shot.
You're always on that diet. Yeah. The
people, hey, loosen up. Lighten up. Yeah.
They want to say there's a,
there's a certain part of people
that want to see everyone else fail.
And if you're, you've got to pay
attention to that to yourself. Yes.
You got to pay attention to that in
your own self because if you don't,
you won't realize it.
But you actually,
I've seen people give other people
bad advice because they're jealous.
They're jealous.
Certain programs,
I seem to go with a gut friend of mine
was going for a certain program in the
military and he came to me, he said,
man, I'm just going to try this program.
But a couple of guys were telling
me I shouldn't. And I said, Bro,
that is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard. They are jealous. They're jealous.
They don't want you to do this program
cause it's gonna make you more successful.
Go do the program. Huh? And
he said, okay. And he did it.
[inaudible] that's who I want to give
peer pressure of goodness out of badness.
And, and the thing is, I mean,
I guess you could look at peer
pressure in a way is it's leadership,
whether you're standing up to it or
whether you're spreading the positive peer
pressure. And that's leadership. And
that's what we're here to do, man. Yeah.
We're here to do, we're here to lead.
And when you use that in a positive way,
you can prevent this kind of,
he's kind of sick,
sadistic,
horrible,
horrific events like this,
like we read about today from
happening. I mean, it just, it's,
it's crazy that this,
that this occurred. Yeah.
And it's crazy that it,
you know,
even even throughout the book and
it,
it's just referring to the Jews,
right?
It's just referring to the Jews
and the Jews. The Jews lined up,
the Jews laid down, the Jews gotten,
got shot in the back of the neck.
The Jews, the Jews, the Jews.
Let's remember that every
single one of those Jews
was, her name was a person,
right. Was bill was, you know, we,
we do the same thing.
We're putting them in a,
in a sort of big chunk of
machinery. Yeah. That they're just,
they're part of the product of
what's happening over here and
yeah, don't do it on either side. Yeah.
Or don't try and have it on the new side.
Don't let it happen. And traffic. Don't
let it happen in your life. Don't do it.
That's what leadership is about.
It really is. And leadership,
the thing about leadership is
leadership is happening at all times.
W W we, the minute you are
interacting with another person,
leadership is taking place. You're
either being led, which is fine,
or you're leading, which is fine as long
as you're going in the right direction.
But if you constantly think you're any
and you're leading yourself, by the way,
of course you're leading yourself,
you're constantly leading yourself.
But the minute you meet with someone else,
you,
there's a leadership situation happening.
You either leading that person or
you're being led and that's okay.
It's okay to be led as long as you're
being led in the right direction.
If you start seeing yourself being led in
the wrong direction and you go with it,
you're at fault. Yeah. You're at
fault. You can't blame that person.
You went along with it. Yeah.
You're culpable for your actions.
So again,
I know it's a brutal,
brutal topic to cover and I'm sure
we'll be back at it again at some point.
But yeah,
let's not,
let's not forget that these,
that this happened and
that if we're not careful,
it can happen again.
Yeah. And you get little things
I can way lower levels. Yeah.
That stuff happens all the time. You know,
like little rights breakout, you know,
normal people just drawing cars because
that's kind of what everyone's doing.
You know, one guy that's like, hey,
stop, we gotta to stop and be like, okay,
let me stop. Yeah. The
peer pressure thing,
that's why people will, you get a
workout buddy, you know, or, or you, you,
you joined. That's why crossfit in
a big way is like, really? Okay.
It's a good group thing because
everyone's like, hell yeah. You know,
like the true you want,
you can't, in a way,
you look forward to just linking up with
the group and the group stuck in about
like, you know, doing good stuff.
Yeah. Working out. And you're
right. And as a matter of fact,
there's a whole new phenomenon
in the fitness world,
which is basically all stems from
crossfit and they call it just grew up
exercise, right? Yeah. Hey, we've
got group exercise classes X. Yeah.
Group exercise classes because hey,
I want to work out with other people.
I want to have, you know, Echo,
call me up and be like, hey,
you gonna make it to class tonight. I'm
kind of feeling lazy. Come on Bro. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Oh, oh, okay. I
don't want to be weak. You know,
you're pressuring me to be strong.
That's good. Yup. True Story.
So use that in a positive way.
Yeah. Yeah. You ever, you
ever been? Well you probably,
well yeah, you probably have,
come on, we can be honest here. You
know the kind where you're like, okay,
I'm going to link up with whoever to
go train or to go work out or whatever,
and you're like, Dang, I don't really,
when the time comes you're like, Dang,
I don't really feel like it.
I in the back of my mind,
I hope that they call and cancel.
I hope,
and then they call, they don't cancel.
They call to confirm and you go,
you didn't want to go. You go at the
end of the workout, you're like, Dang,
I almost didn't,
I almost didn't make it today.
Good thing you know that's common man.
And that happens and I'll tell you,
people ask me about this a lot.
You've got to recognize,
you've got to start to memorize that
good feeling that comes after a good
workout.
Yeah.
So that you don't have to force
yourself through it in anticipation.
Such a good way to put it,
memorize the feeling,
memorize the feeling of like I memorized
two feelings. One is I remember eyes,
how good it feels when you're done.
And two,
I memorized how bad it feels when you're
weak. You don't, when you say no. Yeah.
So that, that's a horrible,
I hate that feeling.
I hate that feeling of
like I didn't do it. Yeah.
It makes me feel like junk junk.
I was just on the road and
it was like,
don't do it. I just feel like man, I
squeezed in a couple of workouts at night.
Pretty weak workouts but just to get
them done and you know what I mean?
Just to move. The worst thing
you can do is be sedentary. Yeah.
And I was moving during the day cause
we were in the water and whatnot. Yeah.
It's a little bit different. Yeah.
But you got to get them done. Yeah.
So memorize the feelings that there's
nothing worse than the feeling of I slept
in. Well, like I said, it works for you.
That's probably as long statement.
I don't like the feeling of I slept
in and now behind the power curve.
Don't like that feeling at all. Yeah.
Like you memorize that feeling. Yeah.
And then run from it.
Speaking of memorize,
are you going to go over everything that
everyone has memorized you saying at
this point where you talk about how
they can support the podcast picture?
Actually,
I'm going to go in and do, Amen. I'm
going to go Ian, at a different angle.
I'm going to say,
speaking of peer pressure,
because this is really what it is.
The group, you peer pressuring me,
you peer pressure.
Everyone else is listening.
We collectively peer pressure each
other and this is what we're doing.
We're working out. There's no reason
not to work out today. Nowadays, not.
I mean this day today, today could be your
recipe. You should work out today too.
You should have. Yes. Yeah.
You should later. Even if
you haven't already. Anyway,
this is what we're doing.
We're working out. Yes.
If we have weight to lose, we
know if we're overweight, we do.
Even if we're for like five
pounds overweight, think
of like your ideal weight.
Think of that.
If you're not that 150 pounds
when you roll with someone, that's
massive. Yeah. And you think, boy,
I wish I was this massive.
I wish I was, you know,
450 pounds because then you
just smash everyone. Yeah.
But that might get in the
way in other aspects of life,
like if you're 450 pounds, that would mean
what, how tall? Like what, six eight? No,
I would want to be like
eight foot nine. Yeah. Okay.
So surfing is going to be an
issue for you, so, okay, so,
so kinda say goodbye to your
current knowledge or your
current Schema of surfer.
Say Goodbye to that. Good point. Good
point. That's just one thing, man.
There's other things. So you're just
thinking Jujitsu lies. I understand.
I was just your hand
and just MMA over the,
you'd be out of the way
classes though. Yeah. Yeah.
So you'd have to fight in these weird
cop shoots, whatever I'm saying,
look at big picture.
I'll just be what I am actually,
you know what bow 700 feet do you bro,
if you want to be that big,
that's your ideal weight. You go
with that. The 750 pounds, 10 on the,
and that's really the point. The
point is, you know, your ideal weight,
you do not me. You know, I don't have
an ideal weight for you. Maybe I do,
but it serves my interim 100 towns.
Exactly right.
Um, and be with less mentally
strong, but for everyone else,
we all know how much we want a way
or you know, whatever, whatever.
So this is what we're doing. Pure
pressure. We're going to do that.
We're going to pursue that.
We're working out,
we are getting control of our ego
temper and other various weaknesses.
Also to facilitate that,
we taking krill oil in for joints.
A story. That's what we're
doing. We're problem solving.
Ultimately it's just one big problem
solving thing, you know? So look,
joints us or Krill oil, boom joints not
sore anymore. Moved to the next thing.
So what I'm saying,
so krill oil from on it.
You want 10% off the Krill oil,
saved money,
financial discipline equals
financial freedom. Boom.
We'll kind of put that
right in the whole equation.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash chocolate
10% off and support the podcast.
You know, we're all in this thing
together, kind of thing. You know,
other stuff on it. I took some
new mood today. Interesting.
I'm not necessarily in a new mood.
I think I'm in the same mood,
but I don't think that's what it is.
I think it's more than just, you know,
balancing out your whole stuff.
Yeah.
I just took it because he was there and
that's the of thing that I won't take.
You don't want to be balanced.
I won [inaudible] current mood.
Yeah, I'm currently, what if you're
feeling angry? Good, then I'm good to go.
I'm fairly certain it's for brain health,
you know, any, I think the new mood,
like mood part of it is more of like a
kind of a happenstance kind of cool thing
like you know. Anyway, maybe it took
some of that. I have some of that.
I'm down for that. There's a bunch of
other stuff, performance stuff, you know,
so if you're like, hey, I'm getting after
it. I want performance supplementation.
That's what we're doing too.
We're doing all this stuff as a group.
So was Jocko our current leader.
I think this is a group without a
leader until someone tells him to stop,
then we're all stuck in anyway.
Also good way to support and this is just
support yourself and support the group
really. Cause you know, okay, so this
book, these books, all these books,
we read these books. Sure we listen to
go over it and it's dope. But you know,
you want to get the book.
If you want to get the book,
you don't need the whole thing. I'm
reading less than 10% of the books. Yeah,
5% it's like a book report.
Although I might've gone a little bit
crazy with Sydney Jerry last week. Yeah.
I just want to do it.
If I'm just full on the audio book,
just start and I'll stop. Seven
hours later. Three and a half. Yeah,
that's it. So got some good
lessons though. Yeah, they're all,
they're all good lessons. How many
people see, you know, podcast,
three hours and 27 minutes and go,
come on JOC, come on for, yeah.
And how many people actually know
what they say. Come on. Echo.
You talked about actually
talk to you about,
you talked about supports
for two hours and 27 minutes.
Come on. That's not my fault.
That's the machine. You know,
I just did a small little party
guilty. Anyway, if you want the books
or one or whatever, uh, our website Jocko,
podcast.com there's a section,
a page if you will,
menu on the top, says books from podcast.
Boom, click on that. Click through there,
take you to Amazon,
purchased the book.
That's a good way to support and
you get the book. Boom. Um, also,
yeah, if you're going to do any other
shopping on there, hey, feel free.
That's a good way to support any solid
way. And that's what we're all doing.
Straight up seats. Now you're throwing
this real heavy peer pressure on everyone.
Yeah, but this is good peer pressure.
You said good peer pressure is good.
Well that is good because we're not, you
just, you're just helping your podcast.
It doesn't cost anything. Exactly.
Right. Boom. And that's what we're doing.
Also what we're doing is subscribing.
And what were you going to say?
I was going to say continue talking.
All right, there you go. I will add,
so subscribe to the podcast.
That's what we're all doing.
I'm subscribed to the podcast
and I'm on, you know. Yeah.
Well obviously we're all going to do it.
Um,
subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already. Also on Youtube,
subscribe to the Allen. That's a good one.
That's where you make all those videos.
Tell me you're doing three
videos a week. Yeah, man,
if I had not seen this in
the future podcasts, video,
video format,
so doing one podcast video and one and
then two excerpts to excerpts minimum.
This is what I'm saying.
Okay. That's kind of,
so we should have a lot of excerpts
up there and they grow every week.
Um, you know, so the,
and the benefit to those,
by the way you make you make your extra
shorter. Why? Cause they're too long.
A 12 minute excerpts, not even an expert.
The expert. That's just another body
that's the same.
That goes back to the same problem.
It's essentially an order you need to do
edit them. Yeah. Yeah. Get the meat. Dang.
Yeah. Amazing isn't it?
She'd just be like boom.
So much to be able to listen to it in
30 seconds and be like, oh I got the,
got the deal here. Yeah. So, okay,
so the problem is with
you as you enjoy the,
you enjoy the arc of the conversation.
Yeah.
See people want to hear the
arc of the conversation.
They just listen to the whole podcast.
Maybe I've been hanging around with
you too though because last week,
the way you were feeling when you couldn't
hand it out, just that whole, you know,
45 minutes of whatever,
same thing you get in.
So part of that is a joke. That part of it
is a series. So you know how like, okay,
I'm listening,
I'm listening to your whole little
segment and I'm going to cut it right.
I'm gonna be like, okay, I'm
going to cut it right here.
And then your little
followup comment is cool.
And then maybe I say something
which is like, Eh, whatever.
I can cut myself out easily. But then
your followup to me is kind of cool.
I'm like, Hey, that's important too.
I should leave that part in it slowly.
It just turns into this thing mineral,
a minute excerpt,
fuck time whenever. That only has the
word Jocko chicken, Mick, half chicken
breast with fine leg.
They're not mcnuggets anymore.
No, actually they are,
but you know that's an exception.
Sometimes they're 12 minutes. Hey Man,
there's 10 minutes.
The other thing we could do is we could
act actually reshoot the like rerecord,
just the pertinent parts of, you can
edit it out without like, yeah, not,
I don't know that. That's a step back.
Quirts I think I'm just making repetitive,
you know. Anyway, that's a good way to
support subscribe that Youtube Channel,
boom, shareable stuff on there
in the event of the excerpts,
not being taught minutes in them. In the
event of them being three minutes or so,
you can share them more sharable.
In fact,
I saw what it was like right after I
posted it and then I think he was like,
oh, I'm going to effing Brady. Maybe
he shares it and then I watched it.
That's how shareable it is. I just
posted it. He shared it and I watched it.
You did it, cut it, edited it,
posted it and then got shared back to
you and you still watched it. Yeah,
we'll technically wasn't
sure to me directly actually
technically it was a work.
That's such a good accent though.
So good.
How I cut the beginning and the end
of that. Anyways, stopping start
anyway. Subscribed pee
tube. That's the point.
That's what we're doing also,
Jack was a store.
It's called Jocko store Jocko store.com
so what's on here is clothing items if
you will, new shirt out. Okay, so here's
the thing. This is what we're doing.
We're wearing Jocko podcast shirt. That's
what we're doing. This what I'm doing,
the peer thing, I'm telling you it's
good. Beer pressure looks who she,
this shirt Jocko is wearing right now.
Even this has become a Jocko podcast
shirt because we now manufacturing victory
MMA and fitness tee shirts to stay old
school to the Jocko uniform. Really?
Yeah. That shirts on Jocko, store.com
this shirt that I'm currently wearing,
chocolate store.com in fact,
all the shirts are on
Jocko store.com I guide.
The master had this tee shirt on.
Yeah,
and the [inaudible] and at first I was
like, you know, I just like, Oh man,
somebody say three guy and then I'll say,
oh even cooler. He's not an actor guy,
but he's representing.
Representing. Yep. That's all.
That's what we're doing
representing big time. And if you,
I'm not saying buy a shirt,
I never say buy a shirt.
I'm saying chocolate store.com.
Check it out if you'd like one or
more of the items on there including,
but not limited to shirts.
Get something.
There's also rash guards.
Hoodies kind of like got to
replenish those. I understand.
But some rash guards on there and the
next hoodies are going to be thick and
heavy Alaskan style.
Okay. Minnesota style.
You know what else thinking on Tana
stuff, not, not, not Hawaii. Hawaii style.
Hang.
Well we could to both because look,
you can't exclude the calm.
I know. Oh come on him.
And it means it means the people.
Technically when you think about it comma,
[inaudible] comma I n means
land. So people the land. Yeah,
I got a pretty good guests right
there. Yeah, there you go. So anyway,
you can't neglect those folks.
Okay,
well we need to make your style
one and a and the north northerner.
Sure. Style. Yeah. Yeah. The
two sides of the spectrum,
everybody wants to represent or
that's what we're all doing, you know,
representing, um, anyway, yes. Some rash
guards on there. Like I said, the, okay,
what I was gonna say is Jack Jack was
the start and we've mentioned it before.
Jack was a shirt.
Now,
well technically he designed a shirt,
varying levels of acceptance on my end.
It's the echo shirt.
Some people call it the Dang shirt, the
echo shirt. There's some layers there.
You might be able to figure him out.
Technically there's more layers on
this shirt than any other shirt.
Really the most layered shirt.
And the fact that I made
it as a layer in its own right. Uh, but I,
my evaluation is, it's interesting.
He was actually impressive.
That design is impressive, like
the layers and stuff. Anyway,
designed exclusively by Jocko.
So now I'm a fashion designer.
Correct. Artists, fashion designer.
Who would have thunk?
I'm neither
technically your bull. I'm
not neglecting either. Anyway,
that one's on there right now.
Right this very moment.
Don't ones on there if you want to
check it out. I'm not saying to buy.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying checking.
I think the shirt it's going to be popular
with your head on it is by the way it
has echoes head on it because
there's a layer in you gotta see it.
You got to see it.
You know what I'm saying is though is
somebody that somebody that like doesn't
want to just be forthcoming.
Like for instance,
a lot of the shirts that we
have that have layers to them,
you don't know exactly what
like no, the darkness, right.
No one knows what the hell a lot has to
do with, yeah. The Jocko podcast shirt,
the one that says Jocko podcast
on, okay. We know there's, there's,
there's some layers there,
but it's pretty,
it's also pretty forthcoming
what it means. Yeah. This,
the shirt that I made for
you with your head on it,
no one's going to have
any idea what that is.
It's so people automatically have some
good layers there just by wearing that.
It's not you. No one's going
to have any idea what this is.
Why is that PR human's head on your chest?
You're saying external people.
Yes. People who absolutely. Yeah,
absolutely. People in the game,
they're going to get the whole
thing and they're going to be like,
holy Taco is on.
Like if you listen to a band and you just,
you have a shirt that doesn't
say the band name on it,
but it's got the album cover. Yeah,
and people know. People that know,
know people that listen. If they listen,
they know. Same thing with this shirt.
If they don't listen, they're not
going to know. If they listen.
You're going to get credit.
Yeah. That's a good one. Anyway,
chocolate store.com that's a good one.
That's what we're doing. Also what
we're doing straight up is in the,
in the moments of weakness that we may
or may not have someone else have them
more than others. But what we do is
we turn to psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
is what is psychological warfare is
an album with tracks, tracks, dig it.
And these tracks,
what they do is they give you a spot with
any weakness or weak moments you have.
So if you're waking up early every single
day and that one day comes or whatever
that you're like, Dang, that alarmed
seller that my bed is extra comfy, I'm,
you know, maybe I'll sleep in.
You don't want to have slept in.
But that's how you feel at that moment,
that moment of weakness,
play one of the tracks,
wake up and get after it.
I don't use that particular track of
use the workout once. So it's different,
but it will help you through it. I'll
give you that spot. Just like when you're,
and I said this before and this makes
perfect sense. This is what we're doing.
And when we jump onto the bench and we
take on lofty challenges on the bench
press,
we're going to grab a guide to spot us.
Not to say he's going to touch the bar
and not to say any of that, but we,
we have a lofty challenge. So we got
the, the spot to ensure our success.
So to me,
if you're not doing anything,
if you're not pursuing anything,
then this isn't for you.
You just got to get up and whatever at
whatever time you get up and go to where
you do whatever you do, come home,
do your thing, which is cool.
That's not what we're doing
though. So I say, wow,
we do our big things.
We're going to get our spot.
It's called psychological warfare. I'm
not even saying to use it, I'm saying,
but if you need it,
you got it to ensure your success.
It's okay. That's good. Thank
you. Appreciate that one. Yeah,
well done. Yeah, thanks. Uh,
also,
uh,
you can get Jocko white tea on Amazon.
Get some,
if you want.
Some also origin main.com if you're
getting into Jujitsu or if you're into
Jujitsu already and you
need a g or a rash guard,
I recommend you go to origin main.com
it's a my brother Pete Roberts up there in
Maine where they make everything,
which is awesome.
They weave the fabric so it's stitching
it, embroider it, send it out.
Jeez.
Rash guards,
shorts made in America and and yes we
are getting in league with origin Maine,
so there's a little bit of a
perfect storm kind of brewing.
Got Somebody that makes
something in America,
something that I like in your
neck of the woods too, by the way,
in my neck of the woods.
So we're getting on the warpath with
origin Maine and we're going to get after
it.
So check them out.
Then weigh the warrior kid,
make a kid's life better,
get him or her this book so
they can get better, faster,
stronger and before you give
it to them little advice.
Read it yourself. Uncle Jake has
something for all of us, that's for sure.
Also, discipline equals
freedom. Feel manual.
I brought like a rough copy.
I forget what they,
there's some name that they
called us or I've called it.
This will be my third book up published.
I still don't understand the publishing,
like they have certain words and stuff.
They use terms. Sure. As our skin,
we're going to do this, blah, blah,
blah. And I say, what does that mean?
But this is the book. This is the book
inside the cover. So a couple things.
Does this have a cover that's going to
attract you know people to buy it? No,
it doesn't. It's got an all black
cover flat. That's what it's got.
Is it got some,
you know,
some interesting fluff in there for
you to feel good about yourself? No,
that stuff's not in there either.
Does it have these incredible life hacks
that are going to teach you how to rise
and fulfill your dreams through
simple things that you can do? No,
those aren't in there either.
It's called a discipline
equals freedom field manual.
It's about discipline and if you follow
it, you're going to find freedom.
Pretty simple. There you go. If you're on
youtube, there's the book right there. Oh,
what does it look like?
Hard to see against the black background?
Cause it's black. Yeah, it's
stuff. So you can see the cover.
That's not what the book's for.
No, no. Bovill the covered does.
Yeah, it's actually pretty. That's to
be honest. That's that you can order.
That comes out October 17th.
The assumption is you might want to order
it now so you get a copy when it first
comes out.
Otherwise people will have discipline
before you and that's not gonna work out.
Good for you. Uh, extreme ownership. Of
course you have it by the way you have it.
That's good.
But get it for your team because I will
make your life easier if you want to do
that. We also have echelon
front consulting me, Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
Get your team aligned so your
leadership can crush your enemies.
And by the way, don't try and
book us through a Speaker's agent.
If you know what that is, if you
know what that is, don't do it.
Don't look online and find our
literary agent and try and book.
Don't do that.
We have a company,
it's called Echelon Front book through
the company info@echelonfront.com email
that. That's how you get us to come
and work with your company. The muster,
we just got done with one. The next one
is September 14th and 15th in San Diego.
It is going to sell out just factual.
It is going to sell out.
It is factual.
It is going to sell out because all
three of the first ones I've sold out.
This one's going to sell out to register.
Go to extreme ownership.com
if you want to come to it.
If you don't want to come stay at
home, that's fine too. Cool. Whatever.
It also,
if you train Jujitsu or if you don't
train and you want to start training.
Speaking of origin Maine,
we're doing the origin immersion
Jujitsu camp up in Maine.
Echo and I are going to be their
training and cruising super hard.
Uh,
the will be there the last day of the
first session and the and the first day of
the second session.
The sessions are August 20 through 23rd
for the first session in 24th through
the 27th for the second session.
Come on up. We're going to be there.
If you want to train some Jujitsu,
it's going to be a good time.
And what I like about
it is that the muster,
the muster is tight schedule from four
o'clock in the morning until nine o'clock
at night, 10 o'clock at night, where
we're moving this thing where to do what,
five hours, six hours of Jujitsu a day.
Sure. And then the rest of the time,
what do we do with the other 18 hours a
day? Yeah, you can say total, right? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I'm saying two hours in
the morning and two hours at lunch.
Two hours in the afternoon.
I mean maybe not training the whole time,
but learning to move. Did you see that
doing Jiu Jitsu showing like, Hey,
can you go over this with me? Hey,
I got a question for you. Hey Echo,
can you teach me that mount escape
that you got? Like whatever.
You know those things that we're going
to do, we're gonna do that. Yeah.
So that's six hours and then we sleep
for four hours. So that's 10 hours.
That's 14 hours.
This is a 14 hours is going to be just
walking around in circles going BTF BTF
it. That's what we're gonna
do is we're going to hang out.
So if you want to come train some Jujitsu,
hang out,
come to that camp up in Maine, it's
gonna be awesome. We're going to, uh,
we're gonna have a good time up there and
until then we'll be rolling in another
place. Victory MMA. Yes.
Also we'll be rolling on the Inter webs,
the Twitter,
the Instagram, and Dan
facey. Butch if ball
echo is at echocharles
in I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally, thanks to everyone
for listening to this podcast,
which is brought to you by our military
who are out there holding the line
against evil world wide.
It's also brought to you by police,
law enforcement, firefighters,
paramedics,
and all their first responders who make
this country safe here on the whole fund.
So we can enjoy life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
Thanks to all of you in uniform
for what you do and the rest of you
that are out there leading,
leading wherever you
are and whatever you do,
leading yourself and the people
around you in the right direction.
Forward towards the goal,
towards the light,
toward a better place.
Setting the example
and getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.